traditionell beginnt die Sitzungswoche
hier im Bundestag mit der Befragung der
Bundesregierung die ja seit einigen
Wochen jeweils mit zwei Ministerin ist
so wird es auch heute sein Annalena
baerbock und auch hier sehen Sie die
zweite Ministerin Bettina stark
Watzinger die Bildungs- und
Forschungsministerin werden sich also
für rund 90 Minuten den Abgeordneten
hier
zu sozusagen Frage und Antwort stellen
die Abgeordneten dürfen Fragen Reihe um
aus den Fraktionen zu den jeweiligen
Ressorts das ganze mit zwei
Ministerinnen der Bundestag hat ja mal
seine Geschäftsordnung Ende letzten
Jahres geändert um das möglich zu machen
damit es noch etwas lebendiger wird ja
und die beiden Ministerinnen die Waren
in letzter Zeit vor allem natürlich die
bundesaußenministerin war viel unterwegs
eine 6-tägige Asienreise in der
vergangenen Woche nach China südkorea
Japan ihre erste Station China das war
sicher eine der heikelsten Reisen ihre
bisherigen Amtszeit aber auch die
Bundesbildungsministerin war unterwegs
im März das erst als erstes deutsches
Regierungsmitglied war sie in Taiwan
nach 26 Jahren das wird sicher hier auch
eine Rolle spielen jetzt hören wir aber
erstmal die Bundestags Präsidentin
Bärbel Bars die hier eröffnet wird
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich wünsche allen einen guten
Tag die Sitzung ist eröffnet
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die Tagesordnung um die in der
zusatzpunkteliste aufgeführten Punkte zu
erweitern von der Frist für den Beginn
der Beratung soll soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden die
Tagesordnungspunkte 18 20 21 28 sowie
die Tagesordnungspunkte 24 zu Beginn
eine Sitzungswoche da gibt es immer noch
mal einige Verschiebungen in der
Tagesordnung drei Tage ist ja hier
Plenarsitzung heute wie gesagt beginnen
wir gleich mit der Befragen der
Bundesregierung dann gibt es heute im
Verlauf des Nachmittags so gegen 3:30
Uhr wird es beginnt eine Aktuelle Stunde
beantragt von der Unionsfraktion zur
weiteren Nutzung der Kernkraft dass ich
ja auch ein interessanter Punkte morgen
früh darauf noch mal kurz geschaut
solange hier die
Bundestagspräsidentin noch Änderungen
sowie die Bundesministerin für
militärteil aber das ist jetzt schon
durch morgen also berichten aber jetzt
geht die Aufmerksamkeit den beiden
Ministerinnen die jetzt die Möglichkeit
haben demnächst für ein kurzes
eingangstatement dann gibt es also die
Fragen
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen herzlichen Dank
für die Gelegenheit als ich das letzte
Mal hier bei der regierungsbefragung war
war das kurz nach dem brutalen
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und niemand wusste damals wie lange
dieser Krieg andauern würde wir alle
haben gehofft dass es schnell wieder
zufrieden kommt leider war das anders
trotz der intensiven Friedensbemühungen
von unserer Seite von Seite unserer
europäischen Freunde von eigentlich so
gut wie der ganzen Welt was glaube ich
aber ebenso niemanden deutlich war wie
geschlossen wir in diesem Moment seit
dem gehandelt haben weil wir vorher ja
auch in der Europäischen Union
unterschiedlich Meinung mal hin und
wieder hatten weil immer gefragt wurde
wie stark kann man sich auf Europa
verlassen und wir haben deutlich gemacht
und dafür bin ich all unseren
europäischen Partnern dankbar Ihnen auch
hier der überwiegenden Mehrheit im
Deutschen Bundestag dass wir in Moment
wo es darauf ankam das Wichtigste in
unserem Land in unserem Europa zu
verteidigen ganz geschlossen beieinander
gestanden haben eingetreten sind für
Demokratie für Freiheit und für Frieden
wir haben aber auch auch dafür bin ich
dankbar fast gemeinsam zwischen
Regierung und Opposition jedenfalls am
großen Teil der größten
Oppositionsfraktionen hier im Deutschen
Bundestag unsere Schlüsse daraus gezogen
dass wir deutlich gemacht haben für uns
als Abgeordnete als Regierung wir haben
eine Verantwortung dass das was passiert
ist und wo wir auch in der Vergangenheit
aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls politisch
Fehler gemacht haben weil wir uns in
Abhängigkeiten begangen haben die uns
erpressbar gemacht haben dass uns dies
nicht noch einmal passieren darf daher
haben wir gemeinsam eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie auf den Weg
gebracht und darauf würde ich gerne
eingehen genauso wie auf die China
Strategie dazu wird sie ja sicherlich
auch gleich ein paar Fragen gehen
worum es dabei geht sind nicht zwei
unterschiedliche Stücke Papier sondern
es geht darum dass wir auf lange Sicht
unsere Freiheit und unsere Ordnung von
Demokratie und Rechtsstaatlichkeit
sichern sie hatten letztens ja schon die
Debatte dass das ein bisschen dauert ja
das dauert ein bisschen und wenn ich im
Ausland unterwegs bin unterstreiche ich
auch immer wenn man drei
Koalitionspartner hat dann diskutiert
man manchmal etwas länger als wenn man
nur eine Partei hat es hat aber auch
viele Vorteile auch dafür werde ich in
der Welt weil Kompromisse nicht
schlechtes sind weil Diskussionen nicht
schlecht sind sondern auch ein Ausdruck
erstens von Freiheit und zweitens dass
man selbstkritisch sein kann dass man
reflektieren kann und auch mal sagen
kann der andere hat auch recht ich
glaube das ist ein Ausdruck von Stärke
und nicht von Schwäche
genau das haben wir als Europäische
Union auch gerade deutlich gemacht bei
den unterschiedlichen Besuchen von
europäischen Partnern in China der
spanische
Regierungschefs war ja gerade dort
gewesen dann Frau von der Leyen als
eu-kommissionspräsidentin der
französische Präsident und ich bin
gerade zurückgekommen china ist für uns
partnerwettbewerber und systemischer
Rivale und ich möchte deutlich machen
auch wenn ich gleich an meine Kollegin
übergebe und ihre Redezeit jetzt hier
nicht weggehen möchte dass unser
Eindruck es waren ja auch viel
Abgeordnete dabei auch dafür herzlichen
Dank leider war und ich betone leider
dass der Aspekt systemischer Rivale
immer stärker zunimmt und zwar nicht nur
weil China stärker nach außen
offensiver man kann auch sagen
aggressive auftritt sondern vor allen
Dingen nach innen repressiver falls Sie
dazu Fragen habt wir können viel dazu
berichten es war wirklich zum Teil mehr
als schockieren klar ist wir kommen aber
in China nicht vorbei es ist eine der
größten Wirtschaftsmächte der Welt ist
Deutschlands ich sage immer größer nicht
unbedingt wichtigster aber größter
Handelspartner und das ist auch gut und
wichtig denn eigentlich wäre eine Welt
viel einfacher wenn wir über Handel auch
gemeinsam unsere Gesellschaften stärken
können das wollen wir das habe ich auch
in China deutlich gemacht überall dort
wo es geht wollen wir zusammenarbeiten
aber wir wollen Fehler nicht noch einmal
wiederholen wir wollen nicht so naiv
sein dass wir glauben durch Handel
erfolgt automatische Wandel oder Handel
sei schon eine geostrategische Strategie
deswegen kommt es jetzt darauf an dass
wir uns von China nicht entkoppeln
sondern dass wir dafür sorgen dass so
wie China sich um seine Sicherheit
kümmert wir das auch tun unsere Risiken
minimieren ich glaube die
kommissionspräsidentin hat das
hervorragend auf dem Griff die risking
gebracht also für wirtschaftliche
Sicherheit sorgen am besten gemeinsam
mit China sie sind bekanntermaßen
Mitglied der Sicherheitsrates der
Vereinten Nationen tragen auch dort eine
Verantwortung für den Frieden in der
Welt daher habe ich dafür geworben in
Peking auch in Südkorea und beim G7
treffen dass wir offen aber auch mit
klarer Haltung gemeinsam für die
internationale Ordnung eintreten denn es
geht hier um unser aller Freiheit
Wohlstand und Sicherheit herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank die Uhr läuft hier weiter
aber Frau Ministerin
stark Watzinger sie haben jetzt leider
nur noch zwei Minuten 50 für ihren
einleitenden Bericht sie haben das Wort
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Kolleginnen Annalena
baerbock hat gerade über die Stärke in
der Außenpolitik gesprochen ich werde
jetzt über das was unser Land stark
macht sprechen nämlich über Bildung und
Forschung Bildung und Forschung haben
schon immer einen langen Atem gebraucht
auch gegen behaarungskräfte wenn wir
alle weitermachen was wir Jahrzehnte
lang gemacht haben dann ändert sich
nichts zum Besseren unser Land braucht
also Mut zu neu anfängt
630.000 junge Menschen waren 2021 ohne
Ausbildung gestern haben wir den Chancen
Chancen Monitor von ein Herz für Kinder
aber erstellt vom ifo-Institut auch noch
mal gesehen die Spreizung zwischen 21
und 81% Chance dann auch später auf ein
Gymnasium zu gehen zeigt uns noch mal
das in unserem Land die Chancen noch
nicht gerecht verteilt sind und daran
müssen wir arbeiten also beharren auch
in der Bildung wenn es darum geht etwas
zu verändern
deswegen ist mir unser
startchancenprogramm so wichtig mit dem
wir ja genau dort hingehen wo die Kinder
ist am schwierigsten haben nämlich in
4000 Schulen wo die und der
Unterstützungsbedarf am größten ist und
deswegen werden wir auch das zusätzliche
die zusätzlichen Mittel die zur
Verfügung stehen in diese Startchancen
Mittel dann auch geben in eine
Startchancen Milliarde wir haben ein
klares Ziel und es ist jeder Anstrengung
wert zweiter Punkt in der Bildung
Digitalisierung ist nicht gekommen um zu
gehen sie ist da und deswegen haben wir
gestern auch digitale Kompetenzzentren
auf den Weg gebracht die nochmal die
Lehrer Fortbildung also den Transfer von
dem was auch jahrzehntelang auch schon
zum Beispiel durch die
Qualitätsoffensive Lehrerbildung
entwickelt wurde dann in den Transfer
kommt damit Lehrerinnen und Lehrer auch
ihre Pädagogik dann die digitale
Didaktik nutzen können ja aber beste
Bildung ist nicht alles wir brauchen
natürlich weltbeste Forschung um die
Zukunftsthemen auch zu
stemmen und deswegen ist uns wichtig
dass wir weiter bei der Grundl die
Forschung vorangehen KI
quantentechnologie Biotechnologie aber
auch Biodiversität wichtige Themen für
die Zukunft unseres Landes deswegen die
Forschungs die
zukunftsstrategieforschung und
Innovation die auf den Weg gebracht
wurde die auch noch mal in Missionen
denkt nicht einzelne Technologien
sondern die Frage wie lösen wir die
Probleme die
ressortübergreifend und die in agilen
missionsteam arbeitet ein Stück weit
eine neue Art auch Forschung zu
betreiben Transfer Daten sind große
Themen die wir in diesem Jahr auch
weiter verfolgen werden die Date ist in
den letzten Zügen sie warten sicher
genauso gespannt wie ich die pilotlinien
werden jetzt noch vorgestellt vor der
Sommerpause und dann geht es auch in die
Gründung insofern ist klar es gibt
Beharrungskräfte wir sind dran wir
arbeiten weiter damit eben unser Land
durch Bildung und Forschung stark wird
vielen Dank
bevor wir gleich zu den Fragen an die
beiden anwesenden Ministerinnen kommen
informiere ich Sie jetzt noch mal kurz
über das im Präsidium beschlossene
erneut veränderte Format der
regierungsbefragung im ersten Abschnitt
der regierungsbefragung werden wir nur
noch eine sogenannte fraktionsrunde
machen der sich unmittelbar
anschließende zweite Abschnitt beginnt
dann mit den sogenannten freien Fragen
für mehr Dynamik in der Befragung können
die Fragen nun thematisch gebündelt
werden dazu werden nach der Hauptfrage
samtnachfrage nun auch thematisch
passende Nachfragen anderer Abgeordnete
zugelassen und zwar im Umfang von
jeweils 30 Sekunden für Frage und
Antwort
in diesem Zusammenhang bitte ich alle
noch mal darauf sowohl die beiden
Ministerinnen aber auch die lieben
Kollegen hier im Saal darauf zu achten
auf die Uhr damit die Zeiten auch
eingehalten werden und möglichst viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von ihnen eben
auch die Chance haben Fragen zu stellen
damit würde ich jetzt
vielleicht noch ein Hinweis die
Nachfragen in der zweiten Runde müssen
sich auf die Hauptfrage beziehen sonst
werde ich einschreiten also ich werde
nachher nach danach fragen die müssen
thematisch passen ansonsten gehe ich zum
nächsten Fragesteller oder der
Fragestellerin über das vielleicht noch
als kleiner Hinweis ich bitte nun
zunächst die Fragen zu den beiden
Berichten so also eine stärkere
thematische Bündelung hier in der
regierungsbefragung da sind wir mal
gespannt wie das funktioniert weil
abwechslungsreiche soll es ja sein
Enten Frau Bundesministerin sie waren
letzte Woche in China
parallel zu ihrer Reise in China in der
sie die deutsche Politik vertreten haben
hat der
einflussreiche seeheimergeist der SPD
ein Papier zu China veröffentlicht in
dem das wörtlich heißt aktuell handelt
sich die Spitzen des Auswärtigen Amtes
und der Bundes des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums von
Einzelfall zu Einzelfall im Zentrum
steht die dort mehr der innenpo Digital
Symbolkraft getroffener Maßnahmen als
eine weitsichtige Politik ich finde
nachdem auch Rolf Mütze nicht der
Vorsitzende der SPD-Fraktion in diesem
Chor eingestoßen hat dass das eine
absolute desaurierung ihrer Rolle ist
und dass es Deutschland schadet wie
können sie als deutsche Bundesministerin
glaubhaft in China eine politische
Position vertreten wenn sie gleichzeitig
von Koalitionspartnern von Ihnen hier in
Deutschland so konterkariert wird
darüber müssten doch unsere chinesischen
Gesprächspartner sich köstlich amüsieren
der jürgen hat für die Union die erste
Frage
Frau Ministerin
herzlichen jetzt geht's herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Frage herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Unterstützung wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe danke dass Sie mir das
noch mal vorgelesen haben weil aus
Sicherheitsgründen hatte ich in China
meine beiden Handys in einem kleinen
Koffer eingeschlossen und konnte das
Papier deswegen noch nicht lesen
deswegen weiß ich jetzt auch was drin
steht dafür vielen Dank
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
[Applaus]
ich interpretiere das mal so dass die
Ministerin meine Meinung ist was die
Schwäche der Koalition in dieser Frage
ist ich möchte aber eine Frage zu Taiwan
Stellen
Taiwan setzt ist in den letzten Jahren
einer verstärkten Bedrohung des China
ausgesetzt die chinesische Regierung
erklärt dass sie Tai waren eines Tages
kopieren will und sie führt
Militärmanöver gegen Taiwan in großem
Umfang durch im übrigen auch in
zeitlicher Nähe zu ihrem Besuch was tut
die Bundesregierung konkret um Taiwan
gegen diese Aggression zu schützen und
den Menschen auf teilbaren in Taiwan das
Gefühl zu geben dass wir auf ihrer Seite
stehen und dass sie keine Angst haben
müssen vor einem solchen macht Übernahme
der kommunistischen Führung in China
indem wir ganz konkret unsere Sorgen
aussprechen und damit auch die Sorgen
jedenfalls wenn man den Umfragen von vor
Ort trauen kann fast aller Menschen die
auf Taiwan leben nämlich das ist dort zu
keiner militärischen Eskalation kommen
darf und das ist aus unserer Sicht und
das habe ich ja auch deutlich gemacht
erstens unser allerwichtigstes Ziel in
der Außenpolitik ist für den Erhalt von
Frieden von Stabilität unter einer
regelbasierten Ordnung zu sorgen und
zwar nicht nur hier bei uns in Europa
sondern auch eben dort vor Ort und das
ist deswegen zu keiner einseitigen
Änderung des Status quotes kommen darf
erst recht nicht mit militärischer
Gewalt und was manchmal hier dann
vielleicht in der Berichterstattung
nicht ganz so deutlich gesehen wurden
ist als der französische Präsident dort
war ist ja auch eine französische
Fregatte durch die Straße von Taiwan
deutlich gefahren und hat damit deutlich
gemacht dass wir eben das Verständnis
mit Blick auf die Freiheit
dieser so für den Welthandel besichtigen
gute als Europäer gemeinsam beieinander
stehen
[Musik]
vielen Dank noch mal kurz zum Verfahren
des ging jetzt gerade schon ganz viele
Hände hoch aber wir machen jetzt erst
einmal diese Runde durch alle Fraktionen
und danach können Sie alles andere noch
mal in der zweiten Runde fragen heben
Sie sich Ihre Frage noch mal auf und
Frau Ministerin sie können sich jetzt
erstmal hinsetzen und ich bitte die
nächsten fragestellerinnen und
Fragesteller bevor sie die Frage stellen
kurz zu sagen an welche Ministerin die
Frage geht dann kann die Ministerin
nämlich in Ruhe die Frage dann auch
stehend entgegennehmen genauso wie die
Frage stehend gestellt wird und dann
haben wir jetzt als nächsten
Fragesteller Andreas larem aus der
SPD-Fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die Frage
geht an die Außenministerin Frau
Annalena behrburg sehr geehrte Frau
Außenministerin inwieweit ist es in
Japan gelungen im Rahmen des g7-kreises
den Konsens zu Unterstützung der Ukraine
weiter zu entwickeln
an dem Verfahren ist dass man wieder so
auf und ab kommt nach den vielen vielen
Flügen und wenigen schlafe hält das hier
gut fit
also wie gut das gelungen ist müssen sie
glaube ich bewerten das ist jetzt liegt
nicht an mir die Bewertung aber
jedenfalls war für mich nicht
überraschend dass wir im
abschlusskommunikativ eine so deutliche
Sprache gefunden haben dass unsere
Unterstützung weitergeht für die Ukraine
für die Menschen in der Ukraine solange
sie es braucht und zwar wirtschaftlich
humanitär finanziell und auch
militärisch solange die Menschen unsere
Unterstützung brauchen damit sie wieder
in Freiheit und vor allen Dingen am
gerechten Frieden leben können wir haben
ja in der Vergangenheit hier intensiv
auch diskutiert was es gerade dafür
braucht dann militärischer Unterstützung
der Verteidigungsminister hat er ja auch
noch mal ganz ganz doll mit Nachdruck in
den letzten Wochen dafür gesorgt dass
das zweite ihres tiersystem ankommen
konnte dass die Patriot jetzt angekommen
dass wir mit der Blick auf
konditionsbeschaffung gemeinsam liefern
auch wieder gemeinsam als Europäer das
haben gerade unsere anderen G7 Partner
auch noch mal der sehr deutlich
unterstrichen was Deutschland hier
leistet und wir haben darüber hinaus
deutlich gemacht dass wir als G7 Partner
eben mit Blick auch auf die Mittel und
langfristige Unterstützung nicht nur
beieinander stehen auch der Vorschlag
von Robert Habeck in der Ukraine das war
mit Investitionsgarantien vor allen
Dingen für die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität sorgt wurde da von allen
anderen Partnern aufgenommen und ich
glaube das auch eine gute Grundlage dann
für die gemeinsame Erklärung der Staats-
und Regierungschefs
vielen Dank noch mal der Hinweis bitte
auf die Zeit achten
Frau Ministerin
und jetzt dürfen sie eine Nachfrage
stellen
Nummer vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin die
Zusatzfrage die ich habe ist Tokio war
ja in der Vergangenheit oftmals deutlich
zögerlicher im Blick auf Sanktionen als
andere G7 Staaten wie schätzen Sie
aktuell die Bereitschaft der japanischen
Regierung ein weiteres Sanktionen gegen
Russland zu verhängen
ich habe sie jedenfalls mit Blick auf
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland nicht als
zögerlich wahrgenommen sondern auch da
war ich eher positiv überrascht also
jetzt nicht jetzt akut sondern vor einem
Jahr und das müssen wir uns wirklich
glaube ich immer wieder bewusst machen
wie sehr
andere Länder auf dieser Welt
bekannter Maßnahmen hier kleine Kinder
und dann erkläre ich immer wo ich
hinfliege da ist jetzt nicht automatisch
jedes Land sofort mit dem Finger zeigt
dort und so müssen ja andere Menschen
auf der Welt verantwortliche Politiker
nicht nur ihren Kindern sondern ihren
Staatsangehörigen erklären warum sie
jetzt eigentlich so eine Unterstützung
mit Sanktion oder auch Waffenlieferung
leisten für ein Land wo auch vielleicht
viele Fragen wo ist das eigentlich das
ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit und
deswegen sind wir so dankbar und das
Japan ähnlich wie andere Länder auch
Südkorea z.B aus der Region aber ganz
viele Länder auf der Welt diese
Sanktionen mit unterstützen obwohl sie
selber Abhängigkeiten von Russland haben
wie z.B Japan obwohl sie dadurch selber
wirtschaftliche Einbußen haben das finde
ich bemerkenswert und dafür bin ich sehr
dankbar und deswegen war es jetzt gar
keine große Rede dass wir bei der
weiteren sanktions Überwachung darum
geht es jetzt ja gerade eng miteinander
zusammenarbeiten und deswegen habe ich
auch so deutlich gemacht wenn ihr uns
braucht dann sind wir auch da und
deswegen wirken wir in der Sanktion zu
Überwachung die z.B mit Blick auf
Nordkorea gibt da ist Japan auch ein
Treiber wirken wir auch als Europäer als
deutsche so intensiv mit
zweiter Appell bitte auf die Zeit achten
das waren Antworten nur 30 Sekunden
bitte im Blick behalten die nächste
Frage stellt aus der afd-fraktion Petri
Brüstung
Dankeschön frau Präsidentin ich habe
eine Frage an die Kollegin Frau berbock
liebe Frau baerbock schön dass Sie da
sind
sie haben nach dem Scheitern der Mission
der Militärmission in Afghanistan die
Parole ausgegeben so viele Afghan wie
möglich nach Deutschland zu holen das
machen sie auch mit Flügen es sind
zigtausende über die letzten Jahre sind
fast zwei Millionen Afghanen hier nach
Deutschland gekommen
obwohl viele von denen überhaupt nicht
integrierbar sind in die in die
Arbeitswelt sie belasten die
Sozialsysteme und jetzt kommt es sogar
dazu dass es ihr Ministerium mittels
illegaler Mittel macht wir haben hier
das Beweis sie haben hier wir haben hier
eine E-Mail von ihrem Referat aus aus
ihrem Amt Referat 500 neu an die
Botschaft in islambad wo explizit
aufgefordert wird in gefälschte in
gefälschte afghanische Pässe Visa zu
erteilen
ist das ihre Politik machen sie das
absichtlich oder machen das die Beamten
ohne dass sie das Wissen und sie haben
überhaupt keinen Überblick darüber was
in Ihrem Hause passiert
Konsequenzen haben
also da sie ja gleich wieder auf die
Zeit bringen möchte ich doch mal darauf
hinweisen große strategische Fragen in
30 Sekunden zu beantworten und jetzt
Falschbehauptung wo es glaube ich fünf
an der Zahl waren in einer Minute
zurückzuweisen das geht jetzt nur stakat
und mäßig und vielleicht stellt ja
jedermann dazu noch mal eine Nachfrage
aber ich werde das alles zurückweisen
und wenn die Minute abgelaufen ist dann
werden wieder schriftlich tun so das
einmal vorweg gesagt haben und einmal
hier laut und vor Kamera wir beteiligen
uns an nichts was nicht legal wäre
deswegen stehen wir dafür dass wir die
Rechtsmäßigkeit nicht nur von
internationalen agieren immer deutlich
ansprechen sondern dass wir unsere
eigene Rechtsordnung hier in Deutschland
verteidigen wenn sie von außen
angegriffen werden sollte und sei es
direkt oder sei es indirekt und dann
gibt es noch sowas wie eine
Verantwortung als Ministerin als
Politikerin
wir können aus meiner Sicht uns hier
nicht hinstellen und sagen wie falsch es
war dafür wenn man ja und Cat und ein
sucherungsausschuss mit Blick auf die
Situation in Afghanistan dass wir
Menschen nicht rausholen konnten und
dann sagen ja und jetzt gehen wir zur
Tagesordnung über deswegen habe ich mir
in meinem Amt mit meinen Mitarbeitenden
genauso wie Innenministerin den Kopf
darüber zerbrochen wie wir in einer
Situation wo ein autoritäres Regime ist
falsch ein terroristisches Regime wie
die Taliban seine eigene Bevölkerung
terrorisiert wie wir irgendwie dafür
sorgen können dass wir Menschen
rausholen können auch wenn es alles
abgeriegelt wird und deswegen habe ich
mit den Pakistani eine Vereinbarung
getroffen dass Menschen über ihre Grenze
kommen können auch wenn sie keine Pässe
haben bei Pässe werden dort nie
aufgestellt wir können alle froh sein
dass Ihre Reisepässe haben können und zu
reisen das funktioniert nicht und
deswegen haben wir dafür gesorgt dass
Frauen und Kinder insbesondere solche
oder Anwältin Rechtsanwältin
schnellstmöglich aus Pakistan rauskommen
können dass sie das anders machen würden
das habe ich mehr als zur Kenntnis
genommen aber ich halte das für unsere
internationale Verpflichtung Menschen
helfen und dann haben wir einen Hinweis
bekommen dann haben wir einen Hinweis
bekommen dann ziehen sie mir die Zeit
gleich hinten noch mal ab ich antworte
da nur zehn Sekunden dann haben wir
einen Hinweis bekommen dass es zu
Fälschung kommen könnten dann haben wir
unverzüglich das Aufnahmeprogramm
gestoppt mit dem Innenministerium
zusammen und mit dem Außenministerium
zusammen aber weil es hier um
Rechtsstaatlichkeit geht da kann die
Ministerin nicht einfach sagen wir heben
jetzt Visa auf deswegen haben wir gesagt
wir machen zusätzliche
Sicherheitsüberprüfung drauf wir
brauchen wir Personal das tun wir auch
das tun wir an unserer deutschen Grenze
das tun wir dort vor Ort das heißt für
mich Humanität und Ordnung und das dazu
verpflichtet mich aus meiner Sicht auch
unser deutsches Grundgesetz herzlichen
Dank
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
[Applaus]
ist in Ordnung weil hier erstmal immer
falsch Behauptungen
gerade gestellt werden dann möchte ich
auch mal sagen ihr Ministerium hat uns
schriftlich mitgeteilt dass die Afghanen
die nach Deutschland von ihnen
eingeschlossen werden gar nicht verfolgt
werden das wissen sie im Ministerium und
ich finde das auch schon sehr
interessant dass ihr dass der rechtmäßig
erhalten wenn sie ihr Ministerium wenn
ihr im Ministerium ihre Botschaft
anweist in gefälschte Pässe Wiese
auszustellen also das ist wirklich eine
sehr interessante Einstellung zum
Rechtsstaat ähm aber ich hätte
vielleicht eine einfache Frage sie haben
hier vor einem Jahr
gesagt Sie wollen mit den Sanktionen
Russland in die Knie zwingen russische
Wirtschaft wird dadurch geschädigt und
dadurch wird Russland gezwungen den
Krieg in der Ukraine zu beenden jetzt
ist genau das Gegenteil eingetreten ja
äh Schlüssel in eigentlich sollten Sie
eine Nachfrage zu einem vorgestellten
Thema stellen und nicht ein neues Thema
aufmachen also das würde ich Sie bitten
das vielleicht noch mal jetzt in den
nächsten zwei drei Sekunden zu tun
wir würden sie die Kurve kriegen von
Russland zu Afghanistan da das ist ihre
Kunst soll ich Ihnen helfen
ich bin auf kollegiale Hilfe gerne aber
ich versuche das jetzt in den zwei
Sekunden ja
also der Internationale Währungsfond
prophezeit sogar eine
Stärkung der russischen Wirtschaft also
ist das ein Scheitern ihre Politik
welche Konsequenzen werden sie daraus
ziehen
und die Ministerin bin möchte ich
trotzdem darauf hinweisen dass zweimal
jetzt Schleusung
gefälschte Visa Rechtsbruch mit Blick
auf das AA hier vertreten wurde ich
weise das in aller Schärfe zurück und
ich hoffe alle demokratischen Parteien
sind das eben so
mit Blick auf Russland und die Frage
dieser Frage haben sie mich ja schon
öfter gestellt ich empfehle das Lesen
eines Wall Street Journals Artikels über
die Auswirkungen der Sanktion der
wirtschaftlichen Lage in Russland leider
wurde dieser Journalist vom russischen
Präsidenten den sie ja offensichtlich
unterstützen verhaftet Völkerrechtsbruch
pur ich kann nur an sie appellieren dass
sie vielleicht ihre guten drehte nach
Moskau nutzen damit dieser Mensch wieder
frei kommt und wir solche Fakten überall
auf der Welt lesen können vielen Dank
jetzt
kommen wir zum nächsten Fragesteller
Jürgen Trittin aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen
richtet sich auch an die
bundesaußenministerin vielleicht hätte
ja oder überrascht es nicht wirklich
dass die Organisation von spargelfahrten
nicht unbedingt zu China politischer
Kompetenz führt sie haben diese glaube
ich bei ihrer Reise eindrücklich
bewiesen nämlich eine realistische
chinapolitik die ausgeht von einer
Sicherheitsstrategie die wehrhaft
resilient und nachhaltig ist aber
aber
sie haben ja bewusst mit China auch über
die Frage der Ukraine gesprochen
und in dieser Situation hat ja China
mehrfach sehr
Ambiguität pflegend schillernd
geäußert es wolle Schritte unternehmen
diesen Konflikt zu beenden in ihren
Gesprächen mit der chinesischen
Regierung welche konkreten Ansagen haben
sie da entnommen diese Ansprüche seitens
China tatsächlich umzusetzen
auch dafür herzlichen Dank
unterschiedliche Aspekte verknappt in
einer Minute
die Chinesen haben mir einen
Positionspapier vorgestellt wo sie
deutlich machen sie wollen eigentlich
für den Weltfrieden Sorgen ich habe dort
deswegen deutlich gemacht das begrüßen
wir nicht nur sehr sondern das halten
wir dringend für geboten weil als
Mitglied des Sicherheitsrates man eben
nicht nur Rechte hat sondern aus meiner
Sicht auch Verpflichtung und alles was
China dafür tun kann
seinen Einfluss oder aus seiner
Beziehung mit Blick auf Russland dafür
zu nutzen dass endlich der Welt Frieden
wiederhergestellt wird ist nicht nur
wichtig sondern all das unterstützen ja
deswegen hat jeder Bundeskanzler auch
deutlich gemacht wie wichtig es ist dass
China auf die nukleare Situation immer
wieder Bezug nimmt hat ja dazu geführt
dass erstmal diese Rhetorik nicht mehr
aus Russland kam leider hat auch nach
dem letzten Besuch von Ski in Moskau
dann die eben Bewegung nach Belarus
stattgefunden das habe ich deswegen
deutlich angesprochen dass China ja
deutlich gemacht hat es darf keine
nukleare Eskalation geben das aber
Belarus deswegen auf die Tages in
Ordnung gehört genauso habe ich deutlich
gemacht dass es wichtig ist für den
Weltfrieden dass man den Aggressor
benennt und deutlich macht wer das Opfer
ist und dass das Opfer ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat das hat man wie
man gehört in den Pressekonferenz anders
gesehen ich habe auch angesprochen dass
eine Unterstützung militärischer Art
damit ein Bruch des Völkerrechts wäre
und zu glaube ich positiver Überraschung
hat der chinesische Außenminister in der
Pressekonferenz öffentlich erklärt dass
es zu keinen militärischen Lieferung von
Seiten Chinas kommt der hat auch dual
use mit angesprochen worum ich mehrfach
geworben habe das hat ja zwar
eingeschränkt aber ich glaube das ist
was was ein wichtiger Beitrag wäre wenn
es dann auch so umgesetzt wird danke
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
da danach das G7 Außenminister Stadt
Treffen stattgefunden hat wo man ja auch
sich mit der Frage nicht nur Taiwan
sondern Ukraine beschäftigt hat
dennoch hat ja kurz vor Ihrem Besuch der
Besuch von macron stattgefunden die die
sieben haben eine Geschlossenheit betont
und auch im dokumentiert wie würden Sie
diese Geschlossenheit gerade sehen vor
dem Hintergrund des vorhalts das macron
eine andere Tonalität vertreten hätte
als sie es getan haben vor ihrer
Feststellung es sei eine ganz klare
gemeinsame europäische Haltung gewesen
diese Geschlossenheit findet sich nicht
nur in dem abschlusskommuniki was ja
alle G7 Staaten unterschrieben haben das
genau das was auch die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin vor Ort
vertreten hat klar und deutlich
verankert diese Geschlossenheit hat das
aber nach all dem was ich in Peking auch
gehört habe auch vor Ort gegeben und so
Botschaft ist ja im Austausch mit dem
Botschaften vor Ort es hatten
gemeinsames Gespräch von von alleine und
macron gegeben auch in den bilateralen
Gesprächen hat mir meine französische
Kollegin noch mal unterstrichen dass die
klare Haltung von uns Europäern mit
Blick auf die Situation von China und
Russland überall angesprochen worden ist
das findet sich auch in diesem Komitee
wieder und der französische Präsident
hat in Paris ja auch noch mal
unterstrichen das ist diese gemeinsame
europäische Linie gibt
vielen Dank die nächste Frage gestellt
Nicole Gohlke aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich habe
eine Frage an die Bildungsministerin
Frau stark Watzinger ihr Eckpunktepapier
zur Reform des
wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetzes also
dem Gesetz dass die
Beschäftigungsverhältnisse in der
Wissenschaft und für
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
regeln soll das hat erheblichen
Gegenwind aus der
wissenschafts-community provoziert so
stark dass sie zurückrudern mussten und
auch erstmal den Gesetzentwurf wieder
zurückgezogen haben und dann eine
Diskussionsrunde unter Leitung ihres
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärs mit
Akteurinnen und Akteuren aus der
Wissenschaft organisiert haben meine
Frage ist wann genau kommt der neue
Referentenentwurf und habe ich sie in
dieser Diskussionsrunde richtig
vernommen dass sie lediglich im Bereich
der postdox stellen ihre Eckpunkte
überarbeiten werden und alle anderen
aufgestellten Reformen Vorschläge so
belassen wollen wie eben in ihrem
Eckpunkte Papier vorgeschlagen
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete vielen
Dank für Ihre Frage sie sprechen ein
wichtiges Thema an es geht um die Frage
wie schaffen wir es ein attraktives
Wissenschaftssystem zu schaffen in dem
Menschen gerne arbeiten das
international wettbewerbsfähig ist und
das auch die Möglichkeiten bietet diese
neuen Erkenntnisse die wir in unserem
Land brauchen auch zu schaffen das
wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz ist ein
Baustein darin ist regelt die
Arbeitsverträge ich begrüße sehr dass
der Wissenschaftsrat einen Prozess
angestoßen hat aber was heißt das dann
eigentlich wir müssen Hochschulen
aufgestellt sein wir müssen überhaupt
die die Dinge zusammengreifen denn das
wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz ist ein
Element viele Dinge die in den
Eckpunkten ich möchte einmal korrigieren
wir haben kein Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
sondern Eckpunkte viele Punkte sind auch
schon breit akzeptiert zum Beispiel
Vorfahrt für qualifizierungsbefristung
vor der dritte Befristung auch mindest
Vertragslaufzeiten damit wir eben nicht
so kurzatmig auch damit die Menschen
eine gewisse Planbarkeit haben die
Menschen im Wissenschaftssystem das ist
ganz wichtig mit Blick auf die Frage der
post-phase haben sie ja gesehen die
Breite der Diskussion die es gibt unser
Ziel ist relativ klar dann auch die
Karrierepfade zu gestalten damit früh
klar ist in welchen Bereich des
Wissenschaftssystems oder auch außerhalb
der Wissenschaft dann der Karriereweg
geht und da war die Diskussion auch
einfach noch mal wichtig damit wir sehen
die Breite und die Vielfalt der Themen
die dort angegangen werden müssen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank vielleicht könnten sie dann im
zweiten Rutsch noch mal beantworten wann
der Referentenentwurf kommen soll und
ich habe noch eine Nachfrage ihr
Staatssekretär Brandenburg hatte in der
Diskussionsrunde ja gesagt dass der Bund
mit dem Zukunftsvertrag bereits sehr
viel Geld für dauerstellen in der
Wissenschaft bereitstelle nun wissen wir
aber alle aus dem
Verpflichtungserklärungen der Länder das
ist eben kaum verbindliche Vorgaben für
dauerstellen an der Stelle gibt deswegen
frage ich sie ob sie genau wissen wie
also auch eine Zahl nennen können in
welchem Umfang der Zukunftsvertrag
tatsächlich zur Schaffung von
dauerstellen beigetragen hat und was
auch sage ich mal die Zielmarke die
gewünschte Zielmarke der Bundesregierung
hier bei wäre
der Zukunftsvertrag Studium und Lehre
den sie ansprechen das ist ein Element
wie der Bund auch die Hochschulen bzw
die Länder unterstützt um eben das
Wissenschaftssystem so auszustatten dass
Menschen dort ihre Arbeitsplätze gute
Arbeitsplätze haben und eben auch die
Lehre gut stattfinden kann denn es ist
nicht nur Wissenschaft sondern es geht
ja auch um die Lehre in den Hochschulen
der zukunftsvertragsstudium Lehre wurde
jetzt noch mal dynamisiert das heißt es
besteht die Möglichkeit mehr Stellen zu
schaffen am Ende des Tages ist es etwas
was dann in der Umsetzung auch mit den
Ländern ist es gibt verschiedene
Bereiche zu denen sich die Länder
vereinbart haben zum Beispiel auch in
der Lehrerausbildung noch mal zusätzlich
Plätze zu schaffen es ist eine
Kombination von vielen Faktoren wir
können unterstützen dass die Grundlage
dafür da ist dass mehr dauerstellen
geschaffen werden und damit eben auch
die Ziele die wir alle haben umgesetzt
werden können
vielen Dank die nächste Frage stellt Ria
Schröder aus der FDP-Fraktion
meine Frage richtet sich
überraschenderweise an die
bundesbildungs- und Forschungsministerin
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin stark
batzinger Aufbruch finanzielle Bildung
das war der Titel einer Veranstaltung
die fand ich sehr gelungen war und die
sie gemeinsam mit Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner veranstaltet haben und
zwar um der Bedeutung der finanziellen
Bildung in Deutschland mehr Raum zu
verleihen das ist auch eine Frage der
Chancengerechtigkeit denn viele Menschen
haben wenig Wissen darüber wie
funktioniert eigentlich Vermögensaufbau
wie funktioniert Altersvorsorge auch
schon bei Fragen eines
Ausbildungsvertrags merkt man hier große
Unterschiede und sie haben hier zu einem
Eckpunktepapier mit drei Themenbereichen
veröffentlicht finanzbildungsstrategie
finanzbildungsplattform und Forschung zu
finanzieller Bildung ich finde das liest
sich gut ich frage mich aber welche
Maßnahmen sind damit verbunden
vielleicht könnten Sie dazu einmal
ausführen welche Maßnahmen haben sie
bereits initiiert und welche Maßnahmen
werden noch folgen danke
ja sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete auch
hier vielen Dank weil die
Selbstbestimmung unserer Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass
sie finanzielle Bildung erfahren dass
sie selbstbestimmt und selbstständig
dann auch ihren Lebensweg planen können
die Realität ist leider noch eine andere
zum einen sehen wir dass viele
Schülerinnen und Schüler auch die Schule
verlassen ohne zu wissen was die EZB ist
und auch mit den Begriff Inflation ein
Problem haben wir sehen das Risiken
nicht richtig eingeschätzt werden können
es ist immens wichtig und wenn man dann
etwas spart auch verstehen zu können was
passiert mit meinem Geld
Zinseszinseffekt was heißt das
eigentlich wenn ich früh anfange an zu
sparen für meine Altersvorsorge denn wir
wollen ja das über den gesamten
Lebensweg hinweg die Menschen
selbstständig sein können die
finanzielle die Strategie zu
finanziellen Bildung bezieht sich aber
nicht auf die Schule sondern über den
gesamten Lebensweg hinweg weil die
Bedürfnisse sehr anders sind ein junger
Menschen Ausbildung hat andere Bedürfnis
als eine alleinerziehende Mutter in
einem späteren Lebensphase insofern wenn
wir mit der OECD zusammen eben eine
Strategie entwickeln um eben diese
verschiedenen Lebensphasen abzubilden es
wird eine Plattform geben die bündelt
die Lehrinhalte bündelt und wir werden
weiter die empirische Forschung stärken
wir beginnen noch in diesem Jahr in der
zweiten Jahreshälfte mit einer Konferenz
dazu es werden auch weiter mit den
Stakeholdern gearbeitet denn es gibt
sehr viele die sich engagieren und wir
müssen die Kräfte bündeln damit wir
dieses Ziel auch die finanzielle
Selbstbestimmung und dann auch bisschen
zu Alter hinein dann auch umsetzen zu
können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
sie haben es gerade schon adressiert die
alleinerziehende Mutter gerade Frauen
sind auch besonders betroffen wenn es
darum geht finanzielle Entscheidungen zu
treffen altersarmut ist ein weibliches
Phänomen deswegen wollte ich noch einmal
nachfragen wie sieht es aus bei
speziellen zielgruppenspezifischen
Maßnahmen einerseits für Frauen für
Menschen mit geringem Einkommen für die
ja ein guter Einsatz der verfügbaren
Mittel von besonderer Bedeutung ist
vielleicht können Sie auf dieses Thema
noch mal eingehen
ja das Thema ist unser ein ganz
besonderes Anliegen denn sie haben es
eben schon gesagt die finanzielle
Situation von Frauen und auch gerade
altersarmut ist noch ein sehr weiblich
geprägtes Phänomen insofern ist es
wichtig dass man früh auch über seine
über die Frage welche finanzielle also
wie sieht meine Altersvorsorge aus dass
man sich drum das dass man die
Kenntnisse hat und deswegen wird es auch
spezielle Angebote gerade bzw
Informationen Angebote und auch
Forschung weiterhin dazu geben denn es
ist immens wichtig jeder kann ja einen
eigenen Lebensweg gehen aber man muss
Bewusstseine Entscheidungen auch treffen
können und deswegen ist es eine
Grundlage eben auch für die
Selbständigkeit
vielen Dank jetzt habe ich noch eine
Frage des fraktionslosen Abgeordneten
Robert Vahle
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Außenministerin
[Musik]
der un- Menschenrechtsrat hat am 3 April
mit großer Mehrheit ein Resolution gegen
die Verhängung von einseitigen
Wirtschaftssanktionen beschlossen in der
Resolution wird durch das sofortige Ente
der westlichen Sanktionspolitik
gefordert sofern diese nicht durch den
UN-Sicherheitsrat legitimiert sind und
damit völkerrechtswidrig sind meine
Frage werden Sie jetzt Ihr vehementes
Eintreten für ständig schärfere
Sanktionen
war überdenken und endlich das
Völkerrecht respektieren und den
ständigen Bruch des Völkerrechts beenden
dann lesen Sie die Resolution da wissen
Sie was der menschenrechtskragen
dass ich ja so für das Völkerrecht
interessieren ich bekanntermaßen auch ja
die fdfd verfolgt das immer ganz genau
was ich beim völkerrechte mache dann
können wir uns auch gut drüber
austauschen
der haben Sie sicherlich auch
wahrgenommen dass es nicht nur den
Sicherheitsrat bei den Vereinten
Nationen gibt sondern ja auch die
Generalversammlung die bekanntermaßen
nach einem Jahr russischem Angriffskrieg
mit breiter Unterstützung nicht nur der
Mehrheit sondern mehr als zwei Drittel
der Staaten deutlich gemacht haben dass
angesichts der Blockade des VN
Sicherheitsrates deswegen er auch zu
anderen Themen keine gemeinsame Haltung
und Position mehr einnehmen kann weil
das Land was derzeit seiner
Verpflichtung aus der Kater nicht nur
nicht gerecht wird sondern diese Kater
mit Bomben Raketen bricht dass deswegen
der Sicherheitsrat blockiert ist und die
Generalversammlung deswegen in einer
United for peace Resolution letztes Jahr
bereits deutlich gemacht hat deswegen
trägt sie die Verantwortung dafür
das Völkerrecht in der Welt zu
verteidigen und darin hat die Mehrheit
aller Staaten auch deutlich gemacht dass
der Angreifer klar benannt werden muss
dass die Ukraine ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung hat dass es wichtig
ist für die Weltgemeinschaft dieses
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung zu
verteidigen sie sind ja gegen
militärische Mittel eins der zivilmittel
ist Sanktionen zu verhängen und auch das
hat die Generalversammlung deutlich
gemacht dass das nicht nur im Einklang
der Kater steht sondern im Einklang mit
dem Recht auf Selbstverteidigung wo
andere Staaten der Welt unterstützen
können
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen sehr
geehrte Frau baerbock der UN
Menschenrechtsrat besteht aus 47
Mitgliedern 33 Staaten haben für die
Resolution mit dem Titel ich zitiere die
negativen Auswirkungen einseitiger
Zwangsmaßnahmen auf die Wahrung der
Menschenrechte gestimmt 13 dagegen und
Mexiko hat sich enthalten und dieser
Menschenrechtsrat hat gesagt wir
verurteilen aus schärfste die
fortgesetzte einseitige Anwendung und
Durchsetzung solcher Maßnahmen durch
bestimmte Mächte als Druckmittel
einschließlich politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Drucks gegen jedes Land
insbesondere gegen die am wenigsten
entwickelten Länder und die
Entwicklungsländer mit dem Ziel diese
Länder darin zu hindern ihr Recht
auszuüben aus freien Stücken über ihr
eigenes politisches wirtschaftliches und
soziales System zu entscheiden also
werden sie endlich ihre Sanktionspolitik
beenden und die Menschenrechte in der
ganzen Welt akzeptieren
[Musik]
die Ministerin hat das Wort
werden wir die Funktionen beenden
Herr Falle hören Sie der Ministerin sie
haben eine Frage gestellt
gut
also Ihre Frage war ja werden wir die
Sanktion beenden nein solange dieser
russische Angriffskrieg nicht zu beendet
ist und auch das ist aus meiner Sicht
eine Stärke das wenn man anderer Meinung
ist was wir bekannter Maßnahmen
Menschenrechtsrat bei diesem Punkt sind
wir übrigens auch bei anderen Themen
manchmal es gibt auch andere
Resolutionen wo Deutschland überstimmt
wird dass wir das dann nicht nur
hinnehmen sondern dass wir andere Länder
nicht unter Druck setzen wie sie vorher
abstimmen oder wie sie nachher abstimmen
sondern dass wir anerkennen dass wir bei
diesem Punkt offensichtlich bei dieser
Abstimmung nicht die Mehrheit hatten
auch das ist für mich ein Ausdruck von
Stärke und nicht von Schwäche
so wir kommen nun zum
zweiten Teil die Fragen zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzungen zu
weiteren Geschäftsbereichen sowie zu
allgemeinen Fragen
das ist jetzt der offene Frageteil wo
sich ganz viele gleich auch melden
können aber jetzt fangen wir ich habe ja
schon eine kleine Liste hier wir fangen
jetzt mal an mit Nadine schön aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
Frau Ministerin stark Watzinger sie
haben eben eingeführt mit den Worten es
brauche Mut zum Neuanfang und diesen
Neuanfang den vermissen wir den
Vermissten viele Akteure aus dem
Bildungs- und aus dem Forschungsbereich
sie alle beklagende mangelnde Ergebnisse
ihres Hauses und auch eine mangelnde
Kommunikation und Tatsache ist auch wenn
man sich ihre Bilanz anschaut dann haben
sie bisher keines der großen Versprechen
aus dem Koalitionsvertrag erreicht es
gibt umgesetzt es gibt kein
sprintfreiheitsgesetz es gibt keine
Dates gibt kein stadtchancen Programm es
gibt keinen digitalpakt 2 es gibt keine
große Bafög Novelle es gibt keinen
forschungsdatengesetz und auch bei der
KI-Forschung wo alle über tschechische
Pet gerade sprechen setzen Sie keine
neuen Impulse und nicht nur wir sind
unzufrieden sondern auch im Spiegel
regierungsmonitor landen sie im und
Forschungsbereich auf Platz 16 von 16
und deshalb möchte ich Sie fragen wie
wollen Sie aus dieser Misere rauskommen
und aus als konkreten Punkt um noch mal
auf den Bildungsgipfel zurückzukommen
warum haben Sie denn darauf verzichtet
gemeinsam mit den Ländern den Gipfel so
vorzubereiten dass auch konkrete
Ergebnisse dabei rauskommen das werde
dringend nötig gewesen
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete schön sie haben
jetzt einen Koalitionsvertrag Staccato
artig in einer Minute
aufgezählt der auch etwas ist für vier
Jahre ein forschungsdatengesetz und ein
staatsancenprogramm das muss gut sein
das soll verändern das sind alles Dinge
die macht man nicht über Nacht ich fange
einmal beim Bildungsgipfel an glauben
sie dass alles in unserem Land gut läuft
dass alles weiter so läuft wie jetzt
dann können Sie das ruhig sagen oder
glauben Sie dass wir besser
zusammenarbeiten müssen dass wir in
einen Arbeitsmodus zusammenkommen müssen
denn das müssen uns unsere Kinder wert
sein und deswegen war der Gipfel ein
Staat in einen Prozess wir bilden jetzt
eine Arbeitsgruppe wir wollen nämlich
nicht nur Bund und Länder sondern auch
die Kommunen die Kommunen müssen
umsetzen zum großen Teil was wir
beschließen zum Beispiel den digitalpakt
wir haben auch große
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation wie
Stiftungen die Mentoring Programm machen
die dem einzelnen Kind wirklich helfen
und das wird die alle zusammenbringen
und schauen wie wir die Schwerpunkte
setzen und wie wir besser unsere Kräfte
bündeln können das ist jede Anstrengung
wert und die anderen Themen wir haben
eine bafög-reform durchgeführt wir haben
die Zukunft wir haben die
Zukunftsstrategie Forschung und
Innovation zwischen allen Häusern mit
neuen Missionen wir werden die
quantentechnologien im nächsten Kabinett
haben also ich könnte noch vieles
aufziehen Exzellenzinitiative berufliche
Bildung wir haben im ersten Jahr sehr
viel auf dem Weg gebracht und wir geben
weiter Gas damit Forschung Transfer und
Bildung in unserem Land Vorverfahren
sie dürfen alle Nachfrage stellen für
den gedankengipfel hat ihr Haus
anderthalb Jahre gebraucht jetzt haben
Sie gesagt Sie wollen sich mit Ländern
Kommunen auch mit den Stiftungen
zusammensetzen wann wird das konkret
genau stattfinden wir sind im Austausch
mit den Ländern so wie es in der K&K
auch besprochen wurde dass wir jetzt die
Themen und den Prozess festlegen und da
sind wir aktuell im Austausch und das
wird auch in Kürze dann in die Umsetzung
gehen
so jetzt kommen wir zum spannenden Teil
weil jetzt eröffne ich die Nachfrage zur
Hauptfrage von der Frau schön
über andere Kollegen der Luczak richtig
der zombeck
Entschuldigung
30 Sekunden nur
so weg Frau Wahlkreis Nachbarin la sie
gerne mal nach Düsseldorf ein also vor
Ministerin gefragt wurde nach der
Kommunikation sie haben nicht viel dazu
gesagt möchte ein konkreten Punkt noch
mal fragen sie haben öffentlich erklärt
dass der Präsident einer der größten
Forschungsgemeinschaften Deutschlands
Professor neu gebaut zurücktreten soll
ich möchte Sie fragen ob sie mit ihm ein
persönliches Gespräch vorher geführt
haben um das ganze zu lösen ohne dass es
zu diesem öffentlichen klar gekommen ist
den wir jetzt haben
Gott geordnet da die Fraunhofer
Gesellschaft ist eine wichtige
Forschungsinstitution in unserem Land
die wir haben die Anmerkungen und die
Vorwürfe Seiten des Bundesrechnungshofes
haben wir sehr ernst genommen in unserem
Haus sind in dem kontinuierlichen
Austausch wir haben auch unsere Art und
Weise des kontrollings umgestellt und
natürlich sind wir mit der Frauenhofer
Gesellschaft in im Austausch und über
persönliche Gespräche berichte ich nicht
öffentlich
ich berichte nicht über persönliche
Gespräche öffentlich
so es gibt ich habe jetzt zwei weitere
Nachfragen zu diesem Thema immer daran
denken zum Ursprungsthema nichts Neues
ich gucke gerade die erste Frage war auf
Ria Schröder glaube ich hat zuerst
aufgezeigt
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Kollegin
schön hat das dem Bildungsgipfel und der
Startchancen Programm angesprochen und
das ist ja ein Thema zu dem sie auch in
ihren ersten Ausführungen bereits
gesprochen haben da gibt es ja jetzt
einen ersten Vorschlag der Länder wo die
im Prinzip ja vorgeschlagen haben 95%
der Mittelsäulen über den Königsteiner
Schlüssel verteilt werden und 5% könne
man bedarfsgerecht verteilen zum
Beispiel nach der Bedürftigkeit nach dem
Migrationsanteil jetzt habe ich den
Koalitionsvertrag so verstanden dass der
Chancen Programm ja insbesondere deshalb
neu sein soll weil es wirklich
bedarfsgerecht fördern soll deswegen
möchte ich sie gerne fragen was halten
Sie von dem Vorschlag der Länder und wie
wollen sie in die Verhandlungen gehen
Abgeordnete in der Tat nachdem ja
konzeptionphase wird fangen wir jetzt an
konkrete strukturieren damit es in die
Umsetzung gehen kann unser Ziel ist das
nächstes Jahr das startchancenprogramm
an den Start geht aber Ziel ist eben
auch dass wir genau dort unterstützen wo
der Bedarf am größten ist weg vom
Prinzip Gießkanne sondern dort
unterstützen wo wir wo die SchülerInnen
am meisten brauchen und deswegen halten
wir halte ich diesen ersten Vorschlag
das ist noch in Verhandlung aber fünf
Prozent der Mittel nach König nicht nach
Königsteiner Schlüssel zu verteilen
halte ich für zu wenig weil wir damit
das Ziel dass wir haben nicht erreichen
so ich habe weitere Nachfragen aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen Star
30 Sekunden
ja frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin weil Frauenhofer angesprochen
wurde habe ich mich nur gefragt und
vielleicht können Sie mir da helfen wie
lange besteht denn dieses Problem
eigentlich schon ist es jetzt ein neues
Problem oder hätte ein solches Gespräch
auch mit Hinwirken auf Änderungen bei
Frauenhofer weil da wirklich ja ein
gutes eine gute Einrichtung in
verrufgerät was wirklich nicht
stellvertreten passieren darf für die
Wissenschaft in unserem Land hätte da
nicht längst was passieren müssen
vielen Dank Frau Abgeordnete
die Frage und die Beanstandung des
Bundesrechnungshof beziehen sich auf
eine Zeit die vor meiner Amtszeit lag
nämlich auf die letzte Legislaturperiode
und wir haben gleich mit Amtsübernahme
auch noch mal unsere internen Prozesse
gestrafft wir haben auch
mittelforderungen oder Rückforderungen
gestellt damit wir eben auch der
bundeshaushaltsordnung gerecht werden
und haben das auch in einem
transparenten Prozess immer mit der
Fraunhofer Gesellschaft
kommuniziert und es geht ja auch darum
es sind viele tausend Menschen auch in
diesen Wissenschaft in dieser
wissenschaftsinstitution sie ist für uns
ein wichtiger sie treibt
Grundlagenforschung bis in die Anwendung
sie ist immens wichtig für unser
Wissenschaftssystem und deswegen ist es
auch glaube ich gut dass hier eine
ruhige Arbeit stattfinden kann und
zukunftsorientiert
nächste Nachfrage zum Ursprungsthema 30
Sekunden Nicole
schön das schulsanierungsprogramm des
Bundes für strukturschwache Kommunen
läuft noch bis 2025 das
Investitionsprogramm im Rahmen des
startchancenprogrammes knüpft zeitlich
betrachtet daran an meine Frage ist
heißt das dass das staatshaus-programm
quasi das auslaufende
schulsanierungsprogramm einfach ablöst
das wäre aus meiner Sicht etwas
ambitionslos denn schließlich geht es ja
darum zusätzlich
zeitgemäße klimagerechte und eben auch
barrierefreie zu schulen zu schaffen
innerhalb des staatsancen Programms dann
stellt sich die Frage welche Summe
wollen Sie dafür veranschlagen um die
Sanierung zumindest bei den 4000 Schulen
zu realisieren also die Frage ersetzt
ist das oder ist es komplementär
sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete vielen
Dank für die Frage ich möchte noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass für den Schulbau
generell die Länder zuständig sind für
den Schulbau und für den Hochschulbau
und deshalb ja auch mehrwertsteuerpunkte
in einem föderalen in einer
Föderalismusreform an die Länder gegeben
wurden nichtsdestotrotz hat der Bund
strukturschwache Kommunen unterstützt
das Programm das im Augenblick läuft ist
eben hat ein ganz besonderen Fokus das
startchancenprogramm hat nicht zum Ziel
zu ersetzen wo wo Aufgaben an anderer
Stelle oder andere Programme nicht
greifen sondern es hat wirklich das Ziel
die Schulen die eben diese talentschulen
diese zukunftsschulen diese
chancenschulen werden soll ebenso
auszustatten dass die spezielle
Förderung dort auch stattfinden kann es
wird drei Säulen geben Chancen Budget
Investitionsbudget und auch für
Schulsozialarbeit wie die Budgets sich
zusammenfinden das hat auch was mit
Zeitablauf zu tun das ist im Augenblick
in der Ausgestaltung genau die Zeit war
jetzt auch abgelaufen nächste Nachfrage
zum Ursprungsthema immer noch dran
denken die Kollegen von der SP
d-fraktion ciao
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Ministerin auch
meine Frage zum startchancen-programm
erhöhtes eventuell die Bereitschaft der
länderverein Paradigmenwechsel bei der
Mittelverteilung wenn mindestens zwei
wichtige Parameter geklärt werden würden
wie könnte die Mittelverteilung des
Programms statt Chancen zwischen Bund
und den Ländern aussehen und wie könnten
die geplanten drei Säulen ausgestattet
werden sowohl inhaltlich als auch
finanziell
ja herzlichen Dank auch dass ein
Herkulesaufgabe in 30 Sekunden aber es
ist natürlich wir haben eben schon mal
darüber gesprochen wie soll die
mittelgestaltung aussehen dass eine ist
natürlich in werter Manier auch eine
Bund länderfinanzierung hat immer zwei
Seiten das heißt wenn der Bund Geld gibt
dann ist auch die Erwartungshaltung dass
die Länder das mitfinanzieren dieses
gemeinsame Ziel und über den
Königsteiner Schlüssel haben wir eben
schon gesprochen wir haben ja auch
gestern noch mal festgestellt was sind
die Hauptfaktoren eigentlich die zu ähm
so Ungerechtigkeit im Bildungssystem
führen das hat soziale Herkunft dass ich
die Frage Elternteil geschieden oder
also alleinerziehend oder nicht alleine
ziehen und die Frage auch der Migration
und da wird man sich anschauen müssen
wie das zusammenwirkt um den um die
Frage der Verteilung zu haben mit Blick
auf die Säulen kommt es auch darauf an
natürlich über den zeitauflauf ob man am
Anfang mehr Investitionen tätigen muss
das kann man aber hinterher ein Stück
weit über den Zeitablauf dann auch
zurückführen um dann mehr Möglichkeiten
für Chancen oder auch für die
Schulsozialarbeit zu haben
vielen Dank die nächste Frage stellt aus
der afd-fraktion Nicole höchst
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin Jungen und Heranwachsende
ausländische Staatsbürger sind besonders
gefährdet keinen Schulabschluss zu
erreichen hier soll das
staatschancenprogramm greifen was
konkret wollen Sie denn unternehmen um
auch allen jungen Chancengleichheit und
Chancen Gerechtigkeit im Bildungssystem
zu gewährleisten allen jungen habe ich
das richtig verstanden ja den jungen das
ist ja auch ein Kriterium und Mädchen
genau statt Jungen und Mädchen ja wir
differenzieren da nicht jeder soll
natürlich sein die Chance im
Bildungswesen haben und deswegen ist das
ja auch ein Teil von pädagogischen
Konzepten die vor Ort entwickelt werden
und die an den Schulen gelebt werden
egal ob Junge oder Mädchen egal woher
man kommt das ist das Grundverständnis
in unserer Gesellschaft das Aufstieg
möglich ist und zwar Aufstieg durch
Bildung und das ist zielschossen
[Musik]
ich hoffe zum Ursprung zur
Ursprungsfrage habe ich jetzt noch aus
der CDU CSU-Fraktion die Kollegen
Staffler
habe ich noch jemanden übersehen
auch noch eine Nachfrage
ja frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin sie haben gerade der Kollegin
schön zugestimmt dass es im
Bildungsbereich insbesondere nach der
Pandemie durchaus offene Themen und
Herausforderungen gibt
Unterstützung für unsere Lehrkräfte ist
genau ein solches Thema die
Qualitätsoffensive Lehrerbildung hat
gemeinsam mit den Ländern in der
Vergangenheit für eine bessere
Unterstützung der lehrkräftige sorgt und
das sehr erfolgreich wie wir finden eine
Nachfrage in ihrem Haus über die
Weiterführung war mehr als vage
beantwortet worden deswegen an der
Stelle nochmal ganz konkret werden Sie
sich für eine dringend nötige
Verlängerung der Unterstützung der
Lehrkräfte in dem
programmqualitätsoffensive Lehrerbildung
einsetzen
das Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung und auch wir in der Koalition
haben das große Anliegen auch zu
unterstützen dass mehr Menschen sich für
diesen tollen Beruf der so wichtig für
unsere Zukunft ist entscheidet das
Ministerium unterstützt schon seit
vielen Jahren zum Beispiel über die
Qualitätsoffensive Lehrerbildung aber
nicht nur ich habe es eingangs erwähnt
wir machen gerade die Kompetenzzentren
digitale Bildung damit wir nicht nur ein
Laptop aufklappen können sondern mit die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer auch
Unterstützung haben in der Weiterbildung
die didaktischen Konzepte zu entwickeln
und da ist eine große Nachfrage die
Cornelsen
schulleiterungsstudie zeigt 98% sagen
das ist immens wichtig dass wir diese
Weiterbildung machen auch hier
unterstützen wir damit der Lehrerinnen
und Lehrerberuf einfach ein attraktiver
Beruf sein wird die QLB läuft seit zehn
Jahren der Bund finanziert sie alleine
nach zehn Jahren guckt man sich auch mal
an was haben wir erreicht wir werden uns
weiter engagieren aber erlauben Sie
bitte dass man nach zehn Jahren auch mal
gucken müssen wir vielleicht auch die
Ergebnisse dann schneller und breiter in
die Fläche bekommen was haben wir
gelernt aus der QLB in zehn Jahren das
gehört einfach dazu nicht weiter so
sondern lernen aus dem was man gemacht
hat was tolles erreicht wurde darauf
aufbauen
nächste Nachfrage Frau Dr Sitte aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE
Dankeschön wir haben vorhin gesprochen
über die Chancen von Kindern und
Jugendlichen im Bildungssystem wir
wissen dass viele Kinder und Jugendliche
im Zuge der corona-pandemie erheblich
gelitten haben psychisch physisch und
wir wissen vor allem dass viele
Jugendliche und Kinder erkrankt sind an
kurvit und jetzt leiden unter
postcode-linien aufgelegt zur Forschung
dieser Erkrankung werden Sie diese
Linien verstetigen wenn ja werden sie in
dem kommenden Bundeshaushalt 2024 dem
Bundestag eine Erhöhung der Mittel
vorschlagen wenn ja vielleicht können
sie schon sagen in welcher Höhe damit
man sich darauf einstellen kann danke
sehr geehrte Kollegin Sitte sie sprechen
ein wichtiges Thema an weil das Leiden
der Menschen an postkowith wirklich
schwer ist das hat was psychisch das ist
körperlich dass man ist in seinem
Arbeitsumfeld und die Familien leiden
darunter und deswegen arbeiten wir auch
zwischenministerien zusammen die davon
betroffen sind z.bundes Gesundheit
Ministerium das Arbeitsministerium wir
sind im Austausch bei wir müssen hier
Hand in Hand arbeiten wir können die
Forschung begleiten es ist schon 2021 in
die Forschungsförderung hier
eingestiegen worden es ist wirklich eine
komplexe Krankheit und wir werden die
Forschungslinie sind haben auch
Expertengremien mit denen wir im
Austausch sind wenn jetzt die erste
Förderlinie auf die ersten Ergebnisse
hat dass wir immer wieder darauf
aufbauen können und weiter an dem Thema
dranbleiben nämlich die postviralen
Erkrankungen sind immens wichtig in
unserer Gesellschaft und jetzt noch mal
ganz besonders mit dem Blick auf Long
kovid-cobit insofern bleiben wir dran
mit dem was an wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnissen ist werden wir auch weiter
in dem Bereich forschen vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin noch eine letzte Nachfrage
zur Ausgangsfrage der Kollege Dr frönden
afd-fraktion
ja Frau Ministerin wir reden über
Startchancen sie haben sich fokussiert
und auch die Debatte drehte sich die
ganze Zeit um Schulen die einen
besonders besonderen
förderungsschwerpunkt haben ich sag mal
Schulen mit einem erhöhten Anteil mit
Schülern im Migrationshintergrund ich
meine aber das Thema Startchancen
betrifft inzwischen alle Schulen wir
haben ja nicht nur 2015 folgende sondern
auch jetzt durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine eine Vielzahl von mehr Schülern
in den Klassen allein durch den Ukraine
Krieg sind es über 200.000 sie haben
vorhin das Thema Bau von Schulen auf
Schaffung von Räumen und so weiter
adressiert an die Länder und an die
Kommunen nun waren es aber doch nicht
die Länder und die Kommunen die sich
dafür entschieden haben so viele
Flüchtlinge und Migranten aufzunehmen
das war eine Entscheidung die auf
Bundesebene gefallen ist also was planen
Sie über das Startchancen Programm
hinaus zu tun um den Kommunen zu helfen
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter ich bin
dankbar Ihre Frage weil dann kann man
auch noch mal klar sagen dass diese
Bundesregierung an der Seite der
Menschen steht die aufgrund von Krieg
jeder hat eine vielleicht jemanden an
der an der Front dieses Leid der
Familien und die Menschen die hier
Schutz suchen auch unterstützt wir tun
das zum Beispiel haben wir das schon in
den in den letzten Runden gemacht indem
der Bund auch für Bildung und für
Gesundheit Milliardenbeträge gegeben hat
damit eben die zusätzlichen Aufgaben
natürlich sind die Kommunen dort wird es
ja gelebt hoch belastet aber wir haben
die haben finanzielle Mittel zur
Verfügung gestellt damit zumindest die
Umsetzung dann auch ein Stück
unterstützt wird da haben wir sind wir
unsere Verantwortung nachgekommen werden
das auch weiter tun
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin damit haben
wir keine weitere Nachfragen zur
Ausgangsfrage dann hat die nächste
Fragestellerin die Kollegin Lina Seidel
SPD-Fraktion
vielen Dank herr Präsident meine Frage
richtet sich an die bundesbildungs- und
Forschungsministerin Frau stark
Watzinger mittlerweile haben knapp 2,3
Millionen Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen Fachschüler einen
Antrag auf die 200 Euro Einmalzahlungen
gestellt davon sind auch fast 99 Prozent
der Anträge bereits ausgezahlt diese
hohe Nachfrage zeigt dass die
finanzielle Situation unter den jungen
Menschen in Ausbildung angespannt ist
wir haben ja als Koalition im letzten
Jahr bereits eine bafög-reform
verabschiedet mit der wir die Zielgruppe
der Bafög berechtigten ausgeweitet haben
wir haben aber uns auch darauf
verständigt eine Strukturreform des
Bafögs noch in dieser Legislaturperiode
voranzubringen welche vordringlichen
Bedarfe sehen sie als Bildungsministerin
angesichts der Situation in der wir
derzeit sind
jetzt sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete auch
hier vielen Dank für die Frage lassen
Sie mich vorweg noch mal eins sagen ja
wir hätten uns alle gewünscht dass
schneller die 200 Euro bei den
Studierenden sind aber wir haben jetzt
etwas geschafft was es bisher noch nicht
gab dass wir in einem voll digitalen
Prozess in kürzester Zeit die
Bewilligung braucht nur wenige Minuten
die Auszahlung im Schnitt zwei Tage
direkt an die jungen Menschen die unsere
Unterstützung brauchen die in der
Pandemie aber auch unter den hohen
Kosten der Energie leiden dass wir dort
jetzt unkompliziert und schnell Geld an
die Kinder bekommen wir haben nämlich
als neue Bundesregierung nicht die
bürgerfreundliche und digitale
Verwaltung vorgefunden die man uns
versprochen hatte in der von der
vorherigen Koalition insofern ist das
ein Prozess der erstmalig stattgefunden
hat und sie ihre zweite Frage ganz
wichtige Frage wir haben jetzt dafür
schon in die Breite gegangen das heißt
wir haben ja Freibeträge erhöht das mehr
Zugang haben und in die Höhe gegangen
aber natürlich ist es das Ziel in dieser
alition auch noch diese letzten Lücken
zu schließen es geht darum auch Eltern
unabhängig das Bafög beziehen zu können
damit eben nicht meine Eltern bestimmen
welchen Lebensweg ich gehe in vielen
Fällen klappt das gut aber vielleicht
auch nicht in allen und vor allen Dingen
auch das mit Blick auf andere
strukturelle Dinge Fachwechsel aber auch
andere Dinge noch mal in der zweiten
Runde noch mal die bafög-formel endet
werden kann vielen Dank
[Applaus]
jetzt in diesem Sommer wird ja die
werden die Ergebnisse der
Studierendenbefragung erwartet die
verschiedene
Befragungen zu zur Situation der
Studierenden zusammenfasst unter anderem
auch das was früher als sozialerhebung
bekannt war welche Erwartungen haben sie
an die Ergebnisse der
Studierendenbefragung und welchen Umgang
wollen sie damit pflegen ja herzlichen
Dank das ist ein wichtiges Thema die
Studierendenbefragung ist ja ein wichtig
ein wichtiger Indikator auch für uns was
wir eigentlich auch die Situation der
jungen Menschen an den Hochschulen ist
das eine ist natürlich auch die Frage
die finanzielle Situation das wird ja
abgefragt wird werden wir dann die
Ergebnisse sehen natürlich wenn wir
sehen dass die Inflation ein Thema ist
dass die jungen Menschen umtreibt es
haben aber auch viel über finanzielle
Mittel gesprochen lassen Sie mich noch
einen anderen Punkt machen der auch
immens wichtig ist es wird ja auch darum
gehen wie ist eigentlich die Belastung
der jungen Menschen was haben Sie
eigentlich in den letzten Jahren wie
stehen sie ähm wie empfinden Sie Ihr
Studium wie ist ihre Belastung als
Mensch und ich glaube das ist auch ein
wichtiger Punkt den wir dann hinterher
auch diskutieren müssen wie die
Situation unserer jungen Menschen sind
sie sind unsere Zukunft und das schönste
ist wenn sie Zukunft optimistisch auch
in den Lebensweg gehen vielen Dank Frau
Minister und ich habe eine Nachfrage aus
der CDU-Fraktion Frau Kollegin
ja besten Dank für die Möglichkeit zur
Nachfrage tatsächlich auch hier noch mal
zum BAföG sie haben die große Bafög
strukturelle bafögreform Jahr zu Beginn
der Legislatur angekündigt und zwar für
das erste Jahr das ist deutlich vorbei
die Studierenden warten bis heute es ist
nichts auf dem Tisch keine Eckpunkte gar
nichts wieder lassen Sie die Studenten
hier warten deswegen die Frage liegt es
denn also wirklich jetzt am
offensichtlich nicht auflösbaren Streit
in der Koalition zur
Kindergrundsicherung an die sie
offensichtlich die bafög-reform knüpfen
wollen dass die Studenten nach wie vor
auf das dringend benötigte Geld das
innerhalb der der Inflation ja auch
wirklich dringend benötigt wird jetzt
warten müssen
also sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin Staffler
ich muss mich schon manchmal wundern
weil wenn Sie wenn Sie hier sprechen sie
hatten 16 Jahre Verantwortung und hätten
schon viele strukturelle Reform die
nicht einfach sind hätten sie
durchführen können wir haben in dieser
ersten diesem ersten Jahr zugesagt dass
wir den ersten Schritt der bafög-reform
gehen weil das das dringendste ist das
endlich wieder mehr junge Menschen
überhaupt den Zugang zu Bafög hat es
hatten ja nur noch 11% der jungen
Menschen den Zugang zum BAföG und
natürlich ist im zweiten Schritt aber
das hat auch mit rechtlichen Dingen zu
tun wie bekommen wir die Mittel aus der
Kindergrundsicherung zu den jungen
Menschen das sind strukturelle Fragen
und der arbeiten wir daran und wir haben
uns dass wir diese Legislaturperiode
vorgenommen und deswegen werden wir auch
weiter intensiv die nicht trivialen
Dinge Arbeiten abarbeiten
vielen Dank eine weitere Nachfrage des
Kollegen Dr Seiter FDP-Fraktion
ich meine Frage bezieht sich auf den
ersten Teil von der Frage von Kollegen
zeitzel und geht damit natürlich dann
auch ins Bundesministerium und die
Ministerin es wurde erwähnt dass der
Prozess der Auszahlung der 200 €
Einmalzahlung für die Studierenden sehr
erfolgreich war was man auch für Kinder
hat selbst erleben konnte das Gegenteil
welche ratzfatz man wäre manchmal frohes
würde in anderen Bereichen auch so
schnell gehen und deswegen meine Frage
sehen Sie Potenzial dass diese Verfahren
diese Herangehensweise auch woanders
fruchtbar eingesetzt werden kann weil
gerade bei der Digitalisierung haben wir
in der Verwaltung ja doch in gewissen
Nachholbedarf
ja danke sehr geehrter Herr Kollege
Abgeordnete
dieser dieser Prozess den wir jetzt
einmal durchlebt haben hat uns natürlich
auch noch mal gezeigt wo der
digitalisierungsstand in unserem Land
ist ich möchte übrigens in dem
Zusammenhang auch noch mal den Land
Sachsen-Anhalt danken dass nämlich sehr
stark unterstützt hat beim nehmen aller
Hürden das sind datenschutzrechtliche
Fragen es geht noch nicht mal nur um die
Programmierung ich glaube das ist fast
das am wenigstens schwierigste also das
trivialste sondern die ganzen
Rahmenbedingungen die bürokratischen
Rahmenbedingungen die dazugehören aber
man sieht ja auch dadurch dass wir
innerhalb eines Monats über 2,2
Millionen Anträge haben abarbeiten
können dass die jungen Menschen dann
schnell ihr Geld bekommen haben wir
haben auch weit über 2 Millionen Euro
schon ausgezahlt
beschieden und ähm über 400 Millionen
Euro ausgezahlt entschuldigung das zeigt
ja auch dass das der Weg der Zukunft ist
und dass wir auch weiterhin uns
anstrengen müssen dass diese
Digitalisierung auch im Dienste unserer
Bürgerinnen und Bürger einsetzen findet
eine weitere Nachfrage hat der Kollege
Ratz und Fraktion
wollen wir öfteren sie haben vorhin
gesagt dass die Anzahl der Studierenden
die Zugang bekommen steigt jetzt haben
sie eine bafög-novelle gemacht im
letzten Jahr die es deutlich geringer
als die zuvor von der cdu/csu sie machen
nur zehn Prozent bei den Wohnkosten wir
haben 30 gemacht wir machen nur 5,75%
beim bedarfsätzen wir haben über 7%
gemacht und sie haben immer gesagt aber
die Anzahl der BezieherInnen und
Bezieher steigt die steigt sie denn
jetzt tatsächlich um das
herauszugleichen was jetzt am Ende durch
Inflation über kompensiert wird
wir mischen jetzt lieber Herr Kollege
ich hätte eigentlich ein bisschen mehr
Stringenz in ihrer Argumentation
erwartet Sie vermischen jetzt die das
Geld dass der einzelnen bekommt als
Unterstützungsbeitrag mit der Zahl
Anzahl der jungen Menschen die den Bezug
kommen das sind zwar unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe wir haben immer gesagt wir
können diesen sinkenden Trend das immer
weniger Bafög bekommen den nehmen wir
nicht hin wir wollen eine Trendwende
jetzt haben wir die bafög-reform
eingeleitet wir sind im dezember 2021
ins Amt gekommen im Oktober ist die
umgesetzt worden zum nächsten
Wintersemester insofern schauen wir uns
jetzt die Zahlen an wie sie sich
entwickeln und wo man vielleicht auch
noch nachsteuern muss und das andere ist
der Betrag wir haben zum Beispiel die
Wohnkosten um 11 % erhöht wir haben
viele andere pauschalen erhöht insofern
gibt es heute ein Höchstsatz der je nach
je nachdem wenn man außer drei Viertel
derjenigen die in bafög-bezug sind
kriegen also auch diese Unterstützung
mit Wohngeld das sind über 900 Euro
natürlich schauen wir jetzt auch wie
sich die die sozialerhebung anschaut
aber wir sind sowohl in die Breite als
auch in die Höhe gegangen und das
innerhalb von 19 Monaten dieser
Bundesregierung und das ist ein großer
Erfolg
vielen Dank keine weiteren Nachfragens
doch eine weitere Nachfrage aus der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin zum Thema
Entlastung von jungen Menschen gerade
auch Studierenden wir haben es ja heute
auch im Ausschuss gehabt ist natürlich
das Thema bezahlbares Wohnen gerade für
junge Menschen ein ein sehr wichtiges
und gerade auch im Rahmen des der
bafögreform hatten wir uns das ja auch
noch mal angeschaut sie hatten auch den
Heizkostenzuschuss ja damals auch
geöffnet und da würde mich einfach
interessieren was die Bundesregierung
auch im Rahmen des Programms junges
wohnen da noch vorhat vielen Dank ja
ganz herzlichen Dank für diese Frage sie
haben zu Recht noch darauf hingewiesen
dass wir natürlich die hohen besonders
hohen Belastungen gerade mit den
Beschlüssen ja auch in der Regierung und
den entlastungspaketen dass die jungen
Menschen immer dabei waren
Heizkostenzuschüsse 9 € Ticket hat ja
auch gegeben die 300 € oder dann eben
auch die 200 € für alle studierendenfach
SchülerInnen Fachschule ich bin der
Kollegen klarer sehr dankbar dass sie
sich das Thema junges Wohnen und gerade
eben auch die Möglichkeit für
Studierende und Schülerinnen und Schüler
Wohnraum zu schaffen dass sie das auch
zu Beginn ihrer Arbeit mit auf die
Agenda mit hoher Priorität genommen hat
und auch die Programme ins Leben gerufen
hat so dass jetzt auch die Umsetzung
erfolgen kann denn es ist zwar regional
unterschiedlich aber das ist einer der
der Hauptpunkte des die jungen Menschen
die das Haus verlassen um dann ihre
Ausbildung nachzugehen belastet und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir Hand in
Hand arbeiten in dieser Bundesregierung
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin jetzt nach
der Nachfrage der Kolleg noch weitere
Nachfragen zu dem Themenkomplex das ist
nicht der Fall dann kommen wir zur
nächsten Frage der Kollegin Nicole
höchst afd-fraktion
danke herr Präsident Frau Ministerin
stark Watzinger laut Bertelsmann Studien
gab es in Deutschland
17.138 Mädchen und
27.934 Jungen ohne Schulabschluss im
Jahr 2020 heißt 62% der Jugendlichen
ohne Hauptschulabschluss waren jungen
auch 2021 befanden sich mit 60% mehr
Jungen als Mädchen in dieser Gruppe die
Förderung der letzten Regierung fand
dazu umgekehrt proportional statt die
Höhe der Mädchen und Frauenförderung
beliebt sich von 20 13 bis 2021 auf rund
16 Millionen Euro die der jungen und
männerförderung aufgrund 6 Millionen
Euro von BMW F und
bmfj wo übrigens die Männer schon den
Titel fehlen so viel dazu dass sei
gerecht unser Schul- und Bildungssystem
welche konkreten Maßnahmen haben Sie
denn vor Einzelpreisen in ihren nächsten
Bildungshaushalt um die dargestellt
Unwucht zu beseitigen und Jungen wieder
gerecht in das Bildungsgeschehen zu
integrieren vielen Dank
sehr geehrte Frau höchst unsere unsere
Programme die wir haben im BMBF sind in
der Regel orientieren sich nicht am
Geschlecht oder sonstigen Merkmalen mit
einem startchancenprogramm kann man
natürlich noch mal ganz gezielt dann
auch vor Ort dafür fördern wo eben das
Problem ist und mit Blick auf andere
Bereiche zum Beispiel die untere
präsentanz von Frauen in mintberufen in
der mint-ausbildung da wo Frauen
wirklich unter repräsentiert dort
unterstützen wir noch mal gesondert den
Frauen sollen überall sein Frauen können
alles und deswegen müssen sie auch
überall vertreten sein
ja selbstverständlich also ich habe
Verständnis dafür dort wo Menschen
unterrepräsentiert sind besonders zu
fördern deswegen frage ich sie ja erneut
die Jungs und Menschen mit
Heranwachsenden mit ausländischer
Herkunft sind unter repräsentiert bei
den Schulabschlüssen und bitte tun Sie
das nicht wieder mit dem
startchancen-programm ab sondern sagen
sie konkret ob sie die jungen
Förderungen an die Mädchenförderung
angleichen oder ob die
mädchenförderungsprogramme dann gestoppt
werden um Chancengleichheit herzustellen
danke ich möchte einmal mit einer mit
einer Sache aufräumen ist gibt kein
besonderes mädchenförderprogramm im
Sinne von und besondere Unterstützung in
der Schule eine Differenzierung ob Junge
oder Mädchen da wo einfach wo einfach
die Situation schwierig ist an
bestimmten Schulen dort wird unterstützt
werden wir differenzieren nicht nach
Geschlecht oder nach sonstigen Kriterien
und insofern trifft ihre Frage auf uns
nicht zu
da müssen sie vor Ort mit den
pädagogischen Konzepten sich
auseinandersetzen aber wir unterscheiden
nicht bei uns hat jeder die gleiche
Chance vielen Dank deine Nachfrage aus
der SPD-Fraktion mit dem
ja sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sie
haben ja gerade richtigerweise gesagt
dass es viele Programme gibt zur
Frauenförderung im mintbereich aber eben
was wo es ganz wichtig und essentiell
ist ist ja je weiter höher in der
Karrierestufe man steigt und gerade auch
im Wissenschaftssystem hier eben auch zu
gucken wie Frauen in diesen Bereich auch
gefördert werden da gibt es ja
unterschiedliche Gründe warum Frauen aus
dem System dann sich entscheiden
rauszugehen ganz wichtig und zentrales
Mittel um hier auch weiter zu fördern
ist das Professoren im Programm das ja
auch weiter aufgelegt werden konnte
welche Rückmeldungen gibt es denn da zum
aktuellen Stand das professorin-programm
ist eins ein Programm ein Flaggschiff
Programm das wir zusammen mit den
Ländern machen weil es eben noch mal
ganz gezielt auch die die Repräsentanz
von Frauen in der Wissenschaft erhöht
die Programme sind bisher sehr
erfolgreich gelaufen und wir haben uns
mit den Ländern vereinbart dass wir das
auch weiterführen werden insofern
bereiten mir gerade alles vor dass dann
auch die nächste Runde an den Start
gehen kann damit auch diese
Erfolgsgeschichte weitergeschrieben wird
nächster Nachfrage im Bereich ist der
Kollege Dr Frömming afd-fraktion
ja vielen Dank Frau Ministerin ich habe
eben aufmerksam zugehört wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe haben sie gesagt
sie kennen keine Maßnahmen oder es gäbe
keine Maßnahmen die sich am Geschlecht
orientieren also aus meiner langjährigen
Praxis als Lehrer Fall mehr spontan
mehrere solche Programme ein auch des
Bundes Girls und Boys Day und so weiter
aber das Mal lassen wir das mal außen
vor vielleicht müssen Sie da noch mal
nachschauen
ich möchte Sie ganz konkret fragen wenn
sie sagen Unterschiede
geschäftsunterschiede spielen keine
Rolle für sie haben Sie denn nichts
gehört von Studien die beispielsweise
die Feminisierung des Bildungswesens
beklagen sie kennen die Zahlen in den
Grundschulen muss man männliche Lehrer
sozusagen mit der Lupe suchen das stell
für die jungen ein großes Problem da wir
stehen Sie dazu als Ministerin
sehr geehrter Kollege sie stellen mir
eine Frage die auch außerhalb ich ich
sage sowas nicht gerne aber es ist
außerhalb meines
Verantwortungsbereichs weil ich nur ja
weil ich nicht für die für für Bildung
sind nun mal im föderalen System
prinzipiell die Länder zuständig was wir
unterstützen sind bestimmte Dinge wie
digitale die digitalen Herausforderungen
durch den digitalpakt wir unterstützen
durch das staatsancenprogramm darüber
Benachteiligungen sind aber sie sind
Lehrer sie wissen dass ich nicht in die
Schule hinein dass ich keine Lehrerin
und Lehrer anstelle das wissen sie
insofern ist es eine Aufgabenteilung
aber wir haben wir unterscheiden im
Ministerium unseren Programm nicht und
wir geben die gleiche Chance
wunderbar ich lass jetzt hier zu noch
eine Nachfrage immer gemeldet nein
sie hat sich gemeldet aber zu Recht
darauf hingewiesen dass es keinen Sinn
macht sich ein Thema so fest zu beweisen
konnten insofern sie sind jetzt der
letzte Nachfrage
Präsident Sie haben was bei mir gut Frau
Ministerin sie haben gerade etwas sehr
bemerkenswertes gesagt nämlich dass nach
dem Grundgesetz die Länder für all diese
Fragen zuständig sind jetzt frage ich
sie einfach mal warum wir seit
anderthalb Jahren von ihnen immer nur
Bildungsthemen hören und so gut wie nie
Forschungsthemen sie kenne siegerehren
sich hier als Bildungsminister überhaupt
keine Zuständigkeit
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter dann
folgen Sie dem Bildungs- und
Forschungsausschuss und den Themen die
dort behandelt werden scheinbar nicht
aufmerksam genug
wir haben viele Projekte auf den Weg
gebracht zum Beispiel Date wir haben
übrigens bei der Sprinter bin ich für
ihn nicht Zuge gekommen schon
untergesetzlich eine Regel viele
Regelungen geschaffen Budget erhört er
hört selbstbewirtschaftungsmittel wir
haben die Zukunftsstrategie auf den Weg
gebracht ich glaube dann sollten sie
vielleicht mal regelmäßig an den
Ausschuss gehen
so jetzt sind wir damit mit diesem Thema
durch und die nächste Fragestellung ist
die Kollegin in Datteln ist äh Fraktion
herr Präsident meine Frage richtet sich
an Außenministerin
Frau Ministerin die SPD nach
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung für öffentlich
jetzt namensbeiträge die darauf
hinweisen dass Europas Politiker ich
zitiere keine Ahnung von den Sichtweisen
und Erwartungen des globalen Südens
haben Zitat Ende dort wird deutlich
kritisiert dass sich die Nato und
us-verbündete auch bei der G7 als
internationale Staatengemeinschaft
darstellen während der große Teil der
Weltgemeinschaft ja tatsächlich keine
Waffen an die Ukraine liefert und auch
die einseitigen Wirtschaftssanktionen
des Westens als ein Völkerrechtsbruch
verurteilt fakt ist dass die moralische
Belehrungen auch und Forderung der
deutschen Außenpolitik im globalen Süden
ja auch als eine neokoloniale
Schulmeisterei wahrgenommen werden und
im Hinblick auf ihre jüngsten Besuch in
China haben sie gesagt Frau Werbung zu
den Spannungen in der Straße von Taiwan
dass sie Zitat wie es nicht hinnehmen
würden wenn es zu einer militärischen
Eskalation kommt Zitat Ende meine Frage
ist ob sie damit eine deutsche
Beteiligung an einem Wirtschaftskrieg
oder gar eine deutsche Beteiligung an
einem Krieg in China ankündigen wollten
das wäre ja für die sozial und auch die
menschliche Sicherheit der Bevölkerung
in Deutschland verheerend
vielen Dank Charakter der nur für Ihre
Frage da wir gerade so Fieber gender
gesprochen haben fühle ich mich jetzt
nicht so ganz angesprochen wenn die
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung sagt
europäische Politiker haben den Blick
nicht für den globalen Süden aber ich
antworte trotzdem als Außenministerin
meines Landes bei meinen
unterschiedlichen besuchen sie waren ja
auch mit dabei in den unterschiedlichen
Ländern zum einen ist es immer schwierig
zu sagen die Länder wie die Politik weil
es auch in Afrika sehr unterschiedliche
Länder gibt auch im Indopazifik sehr
unterschiedliche Länder und die kennen
ja auch das Abstimmungsverhalten von den
Ländern in der Generalversammlung auf
die ich gerade eben hingewiesen habe wir
haben da mehrere afrikanische Länder die
auch für die Resolutionen inhaltigen for
peace und auch für den Friedensplan der
Generalversammlung gestimmt hatten die
sehr deutlich machen dass man einen
Bruch der un-kater nicht einfach
hinnehmen kann dass man eine Verbrechen
nämlich worauf ergration nicht einfach
hinnehmen kann es waren bekanntermaßen
deswegen zum Beispiel auch afrikanische
Kinder die bei dem internationalen
strafgerichtsreform mit Blick auf das
Kampala imment ein intensiv dafür
geworden haben gerade auch bei
europäischen Ländern dass man mit Blick
auf den Angriffskrieg vor dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
angeklagt werden sollte da sehen sie zum
Beispiel ein Beispiel für eine enge
Zusammenarbeit von der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland mit diesen afrikanischen
Ländern weil ich habe ja in Den Haag
auch deutlich gemacht dass es für uns
wichtig ist jeder Stadt tut von Rom das
rumstatut zu ändern um auf diesen Wege
für eine Einhaltung des Völkerrechtes
und vor allen Dingen für
Rechtsstaatlichkeit weltweit zu sorgen
na die Zeit abgelaufen ist vielleicht
nehmen sie danach frage noch mal die
Straße von Taiwan sonst klopfte der
Präsident wieder
Nachfrage
herr Präsident ja die erste Frage wurde
ja gar nicht beantwortet Richtung Taiwan
und zweitens würde ich gerne wissen weil
sie die Forderungen Brasiliens
Präsidenten nach die Beendigung der
Waffenlieferungen und Zusammenarbeit in
Richtung Verhandlungslösung ignorieren
und in der Abschlusserklärung der G7 ja
auch kein Wort von einer diplomatischen
Initiative ist ist meine Frage ob sie
die Initiative des französischen
Präsidenten macron unterstützen werden
der offensichtlich mit China daran
arbeitet Russland und Ukraine noch in
diesem Sommer zu Verhandlungsgesprächen
zu bewegen es wird berichtet dass er
seinen außenpolitischen Berater Emmanuel
Boni beauftragt hat und China den
Spitzen Diplomaten waren nie zusammen zu
arbeiten um einen Rahmen zu schaffen für
künftige Verhandlungen Frankreichs
Verbündete sein laut Medienberichten
informiert meine Frage ist die
Bundesregierung informiert und
unterstützt sie diese französische
Initiative
ja selber mit Herrn wangi in China
zusammengesessen und deswegen haben wir
intensiv darüber gesprochen wie wir den
Weltfrieden wiederherstellen können
bedauerlicherweise haben wir einen ein
paar Punkten unterschiedliche
Einschätzung wir teilen das ist zu
keiner nuklearen weiteren Eskalation
kommen darf da arbeiten wir eng zusammen
allerdings hatte ich ja sein
Außenminister er war ja vorher selber
war nie Außenminister gefragt warum sie
dann den Aggressor nicht auffordern mit
der Bombardierung endlich aufzuhören das
wäre der erste Schritt zu frieden das
wäre der erste Schritt auch wenn man
dann verhandeln will leider hat China
das nicht getan wir haben deutlich
gemacht dass wir jederzeit über Frieden
sprechen wollen dass es in der Hoheit
der Ukraine liegt die Ukraine hat auch
gesagt dass sie jederzeit endlich über
Frieden sprechen will aber das kann man
nicht wenn man ständig bombardiert wird
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir zu
einer Beendigung der Bombardierung von
Seiten des kommen sie haben den
brasilianischen Präsidenten noch mal
angesprochen er war zeitgleich dort wir
waren lustigerweise auch im gleichen
Hotel und da hieß es auch von einigen
von ihnen ja der erreicht ganz viel ja
man hat über Freihandel gesprochen und
da hat der brasilianische Präsident
deutlich gemacht dass er sich das
Freihandelsabkommen mit Europa viel
stärker vorstellen kann als das was von
chinesischer Seite angeboten wurde auch
dazu zu der These dass es hier irgendwie
eine Polarisierung auf der Welt geben
würde zur Straße von Taiwan haben wir
deutlich gemacht dass wir de eskalieren
wollen das habe ich auch in China
deutlich gemacht wir müssen gemeinsam
darüber sprechen warum gewisse Dinge
offensichtlich als Aggression
wahrgenommen werden das hat Toni blinken
auch beim G7 Treffen noch mal
unterstrichen wir wollen verhindern dass
es zu einer weiteren militärischen
Eskalation auf dieser Welt kommt und
auch dazu diente mein besuchen vielen
Dank Frau Ministerin
die nächste Nachfrage der Kollege
frohmeier afd-fraktion
Frau Ministerin wie hat denn eine
China-Reise unternommen die Kollegin
dagdelin hat es angesprochen sie haben
dort gesagt Zitat dieser Anschlag
gemeint war Nord Stream hatte überhaupt
keine weltweiten Auswirkungen wie kommen
Sie zu so einer Einschätzung sie wissen
die Gaspreise sind explodiert danach 14%
ging es nach oben die Auswirkungen
spüren im übrigen auch die deutschen
Verbraucher ganz massiv der Gaspreis hat
sich mehr als verdoppelt und was tun Sie
konkret nach über einem halben Jahr nach
den Anschlägen auf Nord Stream um
endlich für Aufklärung zu sorgen die
nordischen Staaten haben kein Interesse
daran mit uns eine Ermittlungsgruppe zu
bilden wann gibt es endlich
internationale Untersuchungen
also es gab ja eine Frage auf die ich
geantwortet habe und in dieser Frage
wurde gesagt oder jedenfalls klang das
so als wenn durch den Anschlag auf die
nordschweben Leitung 1 und 2 als wenn
dann plötzlich irgendwas passiert wäre
bei den Gaslieferungen bekanntermaßen
hat der Krieg ja schon leider vorher
stattgefunden bekanntermaßen war es
vorher schon so da ist ja auch eine
Turbine zurück nach Russland gereist das
von russischer Seite die Lieferung
deutlich reduziert worden sind mit
drastream 2 war es ohnehin so dass da in
dem Moment kein Gas durchgeflossen ist
plus wir haben aufgrund des russischen
Angriffs Krieges unsere Abhängigkeiten
von Russland weiter reduziert die
Fragestellerin hatte gedacht oder
jedenfalls Ihre Frage so gestellt dass
da ganz normal Gas durchgelaufen wäre
und es hätte diesen russischen
Angriffskrieg nicht gewiesen und
deswegen habe ich darauf hingewiesen
dass in dem Moment wo der Anschlag
stattgefunden hat ohnehin diese
Gaslieferung von Seitens Russland schon
massiv reduziert worden sind und unsere
abnahmemassiv runtergefallen ist das
heißt die Konsequenten die wir weltweit
gesehen haben mit Blick auf die
Gaspreise die bestehen natürlich aber
die bestehen durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg sie bestehen dadurch dass
die Lieferung aus Russland eben nicht
mehr so rauskommen manche beziehen ja
noch wir beziehen nicht mehr aber das
hat nicht im Zusammenhang mit dem
Angriff gestanden mit Blick auf die
Ermittlung gab es unterschiedliche
Unterrichtungen es wird allerdings auch
schon geklopft das letzte war dass wir
per Verbalnote vom Auswärtigen Amt an
die russische Botschaft am 7 März 23
deutlich gemacht haben wie die
gemeinsamen Ermittlung von Dänemark und
Schweden sind wie unsere Ermittlung sind
bei uns ermittelt bekanntermaßen der
längeren Generalbundesanwalt weil wir
erneut eine Rechtsstaat sind und es ist
ermittelt nicht die deutsche
Außenministerin
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin darf ich
meine Bitte Ausdruck verleihen dass sie
sich bemühen auch wenn es schwer fällt
bei dem Thema innerhalb der Zeit zu
bleiben nächster Nachfrage ist der
Kollege bayernsituation
ganz herzlichen Dank Herr Präsident auch
an die bundesaußenministerin eine
Nachfrage und zwar zum Thema zurück bei
dem wir eigentlich sind irgendwie war
das jetzt gerade auf Track gewesen dass
wir zu nordium 2 gehört haben Stichwort
globaler Süden und Brasilien wir haben
gesehen dass China sie strategischen
Einfluss weltweit ausbaut und die Frau
bundesaußenministerin hat ja gerade auch
darauf hingewiesen dass der
brasilianische Staatspräsident Luder das
Silva zur gleichen Zeit sogar im
gleichen Hotel in China unterwegs war
ähm es ist nun so dass Lula das silver
hier sozusagen auch von der
Bundesregierung umworben wird meine
Frage ist sie wie entgegnen sie der
Tatsache dass Luder das Silber China
Umwelt
die Ukraine auffordert die Krim
abzugeben lavrot vorgestern noch
empfangen hat in Brasilien und iranische
Kriegsschiffe im Hafen von Rio de
Janeiro andocken lässt wie gehen Sie mit
diesem neuen von ihnen umworbenen
Partner um
deutlich wie komplex nicht nur die Welt
ist sondern auch die unterschiedlichen
bilateralen Beziehungen oder die
unterschiedlichen Beziehungen der
Europäischen Union mit unterschiedlichen
Ländern deswegen Differenziertheit so
wichtig ist und ich schwarz oder weiß
und das gleiche was für China gilt aus
meiner Sicht jedenfalls dass man im
Dialog sein kann und trotzdem einen
klaren Standpunkt beziehen kann dass das
kein Widerspruch ist sondern dass das in
so einer komplexen Beziehung wie wir sie
mit China haben gerade weil China sich
so stark verändert hat dass das wichtig
ist und das gleiche gilt auch für mich
wie Länder wie Brasilien die natürlich
noch mal ganz anders sind als gefestigte
Demokratie auch das möchte ich
unterstreichen den Regierungswechsel den
es da ja gegeben hat auch ein ganz ganz
intensiven Wahlkampf macht halt deutlich
was der Unterschied ist zwischen
Demokratien und autokratischen Regime
brasilien ist ein Schlüsselpartner für
uns und strategischer Partner in
Lateinamerika aber wir haben mit
Brasilien in unterschiedlichen Themen
auch unterschiedliche Unterhaltung beim
Freihandelsabkommen habe ich ja bereits
deutlich gemacht sind wir näher zusammen
als man das vielleicht gedacht hat
gerade auch beim Waldschutz das ist der
große Unterschied zu China weil es eben
Brasilien so wichtig ist gerade Klima
und Umweltstandards mit zu verankern bei
anderen Themen wie zum Beispiel mit
Blick auf die Verurteilung des
russischen Angriffskrieg bedauern wir
sehr das machen wir auch immer wieder
deutlich der Kanzler der
Wirtschaftsminister und auch wenn ich
die mädchenreisen werde dass wir auch
für Brasilien eine Verantwortung sehen
ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen dass
Brasilien auch vielleicht noch mal an
die Frage der vorfragestellerin
hinweisen dass Brasilien auch in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen mit der Resolution gestimmt hat
die deutlich gemacht hat Russland ist
der Angreifer Russland muss seine
Bombardierung einstellen die Ukraine ist
das Opfer und hat ein Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung
vielen Dank
Vorletzter Nachfrage zu dieser
Fragestellung SPD-Fraktion
viel vielen Dank herr Präsident es geht
auch nochmal an die Frau Außenministerin
nochmal zurück zu dem zu der
Ursprungsfrage G7 und Frieden
Frau Ministerin inwieweit waren denn
eventuelle militärischen
Sicherheitsgarantien für die Ukraine
nach einem Waffen nach einem möglichen
Waffenstillstand Thema bei den
g7-beratungen
das war auch Thema aber so ein Mehrwert
gerade von diesen Treffen das war ja
auch ein besserer längerer Zeitraum als
einfach nur zwei Stunden sich zu treffen
und dann auch aus Sicherheitsgründen
aber es hat große Vorteile auch da
wieder Handys abzugeben dann diskutiert
man nämlich sehr intensiv und vor allen
Dingen an so einem kleinen runden Tisch
das war natürlich auch ein Thema aber
weil es eben dort auch viele Fragen gibt
auch im Rahmen der NATO kurz vorher war
ja auch das nato-treffen der
Außenminister gehe ich jetzt darauf
nicht ein aber natürlich sind die
Sicherheit Garantien für die Ukraine ein
großes Thema auf unterschiedlicher Ebene
die Ukraine ist EU Beitrittskandidat
auch da haben wir dann
solidaritätsklauseln die Ukraine würden
noch enger mit uns im Rahmen der NATO
Zusammenarbeiten mit Blick auf die
Unterstützung das haben wir beim
Außenministerin und Außenminister
treffen bereits deutlich gemacht und im
G7 haben wir bereits deutlich gemacht
dass wir eine Mittel und langfristige
Unterstützung der Ukraine haben
wirtschaftlich finanziell aber eben auch
im militärischen Bereich und eben das
heißt dann auch mit Blick auf ja Pan die
ja Mitglied sind auch mit Blick aus
Japanern vielen Dank Frau Minister
Nachfrage bei Ihnen jetzt noch in der
Mitte dann sind sie die letzte jetzt in
dieser Nachfrage eine eine Nachfrage
oder nicht nein Frau Kraft ist die
nächste
vielen vielen Dank herr Präsident Frau
Ministerin will mir gerade über
internationale Beziehungen sprechen da
möchte ich die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik ansprechen die sich ja
als sehr wichtig vor allen Dingen seit
dem Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
erwiesen hat und meine Frage ist an
dieser Stelle inwiefern man die
auswärtige Kultur und Bildungspolitik
als ein Aspekt moderner Geopolitik
begreifen kann und was die
Bundesregierung plant um die auswärtige
Kultur und Bildungspolitik zu stärken
danke
auch diese weitere unterstützen wir sind
ja bekanntermaßen auch gerade in
Haushaltsverhandlungen und auch da ist
das glaube ich wichtig dass wir eng im
Austausch sind das Auswärtige Amt ist ja
ein Ministerium was er im Vergleich zu
anderen ein relativ kleinen Haushalt hat
das heißt wenn wir jetzt mit Blick auf
die Schuldenbremse wenn wir jetzt mit
Blick auf unsere Maßnahmen die wir
weltweit ergreifen jeder einzelne in
seinen Einzelplänen reduzieren muss dann
ist die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik die bei einem Haushalt
derzeit von über 7 Milliarden Euro bei
mir eine Milliarde Euro ausmacht eben
auch dann im Zweifel mit betroffen
deswegen werde ich dafür dass wir gerade
in diesen Zeiten von geostrategischen
Herausforderungen die besondere
Wichtigkeit eben nicht nur von
militärischer Unterstützung sondern
gerade auch von Außenpolitik wenn man
Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit und
Diplomatie auch daran deutlich machen
dass es hier nicht zu drastischen
Mittelkürzungen kommt wir haben erlebt
dass
falsche narrative ein Teil auch von
kriegs-propaganda sein können auch
geopolitischer Propaganda sein könnt und
wir nicht eben nicht nur als Auswärtiges
Amt sondern mit unseren Stiftungen mit
unseren kulturmittlern mit den
Goethe-Instituten dafür werben können
dass wir an den schon unterschiedlichen
Orten der Welt ein gemeinsames Interesse
an einer regelbasierten Ordnung haben
auch über die auswärtige Kultur und
Bildungspolitik vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin damit ist dieser diese Frage
abschließend behandelt ich rufe auch die
nächste Fragestellerin Sandra Detzner
mindestens 90 die Grünen
das mag alles sein aber ich lasse es
nicht zuhören ne und zwar deshalb weil
wir weiterkommen wollen das macht ja
nichts sie melden sich unheimlich viele
Leute und die kommen nicht alle dran und
ja die Fraktion hatte eine Nachfrage
dazu und dann hat die Union eine die SPD
eine die Grünen eine und jetzt die
nächste Fragestellerin
herr Präsident
Frau Ministerin sie hatten in ihrem
eingangs stellt man ja sehr klar gemacht
dass das letzte Jahr sehr entscheidend
war für die Wahrnehmung von Resilienz
und von einem neuen Risikomanagement
dass wir brauchen für Deutschland und
Europa die deutsche Wirtschaft
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher haben groß
stark dafür bezahlt das ist in den
früheren Bundesregierungen kein
Risiko-Management gegenüber dieser hohen
Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas gab nun
ist also die Abhängigkeit von China in
vielen Bereichen der deutschen
Wirtschaft noch mit Vielfaches größer
und ich frage Sie in diesem Zusammenhang
wie Sie welche Bedeutung sie eine
Risikomanagement in Bezug gerade auf die
kritische Infrastruktur in Deutschland
und Europa bei messen wir diskutieren
jetzt in unterschiedlichen Bereichen bei
Hochtechnologien konkrete
Anwendungsfälle da würde mich ihre
Einschätzung interessieren herzlichen
Dank
Dank das war auch ein Teil meiner
Gespräche in China gerade mit den
deutschen Wirtschaftsvertretern und
haben die unterschiedlichen Akteure sei
es von Automobilherstellern
Chemiekonzernen Mittelstand aber auch
Unternehmensberatung mit Blick auf die
Tätigkeit von Anwältinnen und Anwälten
vor Ort deutlich gemacht wie wichtig es
ist die wirtschaftliche Sicherheit
Deutschlands bei unseren Beziehungen
auch insbesondere bei unseren
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen stärker in
den Blick zu nehmen deswegen
unterscheiden wir sind ja gerade in der
Bearbeitung der china-strategie in
unterschiedliche Bereiche zum einen bei
der Produktion in China wo viele
deutsche Unternehmen deutlich machen sie
gehen viel stärker auf China für China
Produktion das ist ein Riesenmarkt wo
man natürlich ist auch wichtig ist dass
die deutsche Wirtschaft da vertreten ist
aber das Risiko die dieser Markt auch
mit sich bringt auch das haben die
wirtschaftsvertreterinnen und Vertreter
vor deutlich unterstrichen dass sie
dieses Risiko sehen das darf nicht zu
einem heimischen Risiko für unseren
europäischen Markt werden weswegen die
Strategien die unterstützen mir sehr der
deutschen Wirtschaft stärker China für
China zu produzieren und gerade bei
kritischen Produkten und das ist auch
Teil der china-strategie was wir in
Laien machen mit der Europäischen
Kommission zu sagen und was sind Importe
was sind Sektoren was sind Branchen die
so unsere nationale Sicherheit betreffen
wie zum Beispiel Medikamente weswegen
das Gesundheitsministerium jetzt stärker
darauf achtet was müssen wir auch in
Europa herstellen kritis ist das
Stichwort für den anderen Bereich mit
unserer
Infrastruktur dass wir bei Investitionen
in unsere Wirtschaft insbesondere in
kritis reflektieren müssen was sind die
Fehler der Vergangenheit wir haben
gesehen wenn zum Beispiel ein Hafen
selber meldet ob er kritische
Infrastruktur ist dann unterläuft da
offensichtlich auch mal ein Fehler das
ist einer der Punkte was hier in der
Gesetzgebung jetzt auch gerade geändert
wird und es wird weitere Maßnahmen geben
um auch hier dafür zu sorgen das was
China macht ihre kritische Infrastruktur
zu schützen dass wir ähnliches auch bei
uns ermöglichen damit wir auch hier für
Sicherheit sorgen
vielen Dank sie haben eine Nachfrage ich
will darauf hinweisen Frau Ministerin
sie überschreiten regelmäßig ihre
Redezeit und das Dreifache und ich würde
doch darum bitten dass Sie darauf achten
vielleicht in der Kürze zusammenzufassen
dass sie uns zu sagen haben sie haben
eine Nachfrage von Kollegen
herzlichen Dank für die Antwort ich
würde in dem Zusammenhang noch mal
nachfragen welche Bedeutung ist auch
gerade hat dass wir im Rahmen der WTO
bei einer regelbasierten Handelspolitik
bleiben die ist unter vielen Aspekten
auch unter Druck und insbesondere da
glaube ich war sehr sinnvoll noch mal
vom g7-treffen auch die Nachricht zu
senden dass die G7 da geschlossen stehen
deswegen noch mal die Frage wie groß ist
die Chance dass wir da auch zügig
Fortschritte wieder machen können
Faktoren die wichtig sind gerade zur
Stärkung auch von internationalen
Institutionen hier bei der WTO zum
Beispiel ist auch ein Punkt wer sitzt
diesen Gremien eigentlich vor auch das
ist im Übrigen eine
strategiefrage wie wir Kandidaturen
unterstützen bei unterschiedlichen
internationalen Organisationen die dann
aus unserer Sicht auch dafür sorgen dass
die Werte und die Interessen dieser
Organisation auch entsprechend
durchgesetzt werden wir haben eine
andere Organisation die in Rom sitzt wo
wir deutlich machen dass es auch gewisse
Kandidaturen gibt wo das Gegenteil
nämlich nicht die Stärkung der das
internationalen Rechts verfolgt wird
sondern eher die Ausbildung und das ist
bei der WTO glaube ich jetzt gerade auch
ein Moment wodurch den neuen Vorsitz wir
für weitere Form werden können das habe
ich auch in China getan die wird hier oh
ist dazu da um weil wir alle
Wettbewerber sind wir sind ja nicht nur
Wettbewerber mit China auch Europäer und
Amerikaner sind Wettbewerber wir sind
alle auch wirtschaftliche Wettbewerber
aber was wir wollen ist das
Streitigkeiten fair beigelegt werden und
dazu dient die WTO und die Reform
vielen Dank ich habe vier Nachfragen
natürlich noch zulasse wir schreiben der
etwas die Zeit der Befragung reduzieren
die Fragestunde die vier nachfragen sind
folgender Reihenfolge Kubaner
Müller und Lambsdorff zum Schluss
herr Präsident meine Frage geht auch
noch mal an die Außenministerin sie
haben den Hafen angesprochen und die
Diskussion rund ums Thema cosco von
daher mal Nachfrage ob sie die
Auffassung aus ihrer Bundestagsfraktion
teilen das ist ein großer Fehler war
dass der Bundeskanzler die vollständige
Untersagung einer chinesischen
Beteiligung beim Container Terminal im
Hamburger Hafen verhindert hat
die nette eine intensive Diskussion dazu
wurde alles gesagt das können Sie alles
nachlesen wir haben jetzt den Fall dass
der diejenigen die hätten melden müssen
offensichtlich falsch gemeldet haben das
BSI hat deswegen deutlich gesagt dass
dieser Verwaltungsakt noch mal überprüft
werden muss und das werden wir jetzt als
Bundesregierung tun
vielen Dank nächste Nachfrage hat die
hat der Kollege Kräuter afd-fraktion
pro Frau Bundesministerin sie sehen ja
uns treibt ihre China-Reise oben hierzu
mal eine ganz praktische Frage es ist ja
geübte Praxis in diesem Haus dass wenn
Minister Reisen an dieses Haus an die
Abgeordneten Einladung zur Mitreise und
zur Darstellung der eigenen politischen
Meinung im Ausland geboten werden uns
ist als AFD aufgefallen dass ihr Haus
das Außenministerium noch nie eine
Einladung unter ihrer Leitung an unsere
Fraktion ausgesprochen hat wir haben da
mal beim Parlament und
kabinettsreferaten nachgefragt die
Smiley die Antwort war die Ministerin
entscheidet selber wen sie auf
Auslandsreisen mitnimmt deshalb die
Frage wie vereinbaren Sie das mit ihrer
Neutralitätspflicht als Bundesministerin
hier eine Fraktion so konsequent
auszuschließen
in dem das was in meiner Hoheit steht
nämlich Abgeordnete mitzunehmen um die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in der Welt
zu repräsentieren und die
Bundesregierung ich bin ja Ministerin
der Bundesregierung und wir haben gerade
bei diesem zentralen Thema das hören wir
hier ja regelmäßig im Bundestag ich habe
hier eben deutlich gemacht dass wenn
Fragen keine Fragen sind sondern
Behauptungen die ich so nicht da stehen
lassen kann dass ich es wichtig finde
für meine Amtsausübung die
reisebesetzung sofort zu nehmen wie ich
das getan habe ich schaue mir jede Reise
einzeln an und werde das auch in der
Zukunft genauso handhaben
vielen Dank weitere
Nachfrage die Kolleginnen Bürger
Fraktion DIE LINKE
vielen Dank die Kollegin hat vom letzten
Jahr als krisenhaften Jahr gesprochen
die Krise eine Krisenregion war
Afghanistan bzw ist Afghanistan sie
haben selbst gesagt bei der Evakuierung
aus Afghanistan zählt jeder Tag
mittlerweile sind 35 Menschen mit einer
Aufnahme Zusage gestorben das ist eine
Tragödie und jetzt haben sie auch noch
aufgrund einer rechten Hetzkampagne
einer rechten Medienkampagne die
Visaerteilung ausgesetzt das ist aus
meiner Sicht völlig unverhältnismäßig
denn Menschen die schon ein Visum
bekommen haben dürfen jetzt nicht
ausreisen und das obwohl der
Krisenmechanismus ja bei dem Einzelfall
gegriffen hat dass es völlig
unverhältnismäßig mich kontaktieren
jeden Tag Menschen aus Afghanistan was
soll ich Ihnen antworten wann können Sie
einreisen
das schwierig immer in 30 Sekunden weil
sie jetzt auch die unterschiedlichen
Bereiche zusammengeworfen haben die
Menschen die sie aus Afghanistan
kontaktieren das ist eins unser größten
Probleme dass die Taliban die Menschen
aus Afghanistan nicht mehr ausreisen
lassen können wir haben da mehrere
Menschen die eigentlich in unser
bundesaufnahmeprogramm passend für sie
wurde das gestrickt ich hatte ja
Vereinbarung auch mit Pakistan getroffen
dass die Menschen nach Pakistan kommen
können die Taliban lassen die Menschen
nicht mehr raus erst haben sie keine
Pässe ausgestellt jetzt lassen Sie sie
komplett nicht mehr raus das ist ein
Bereich den können wir leider nicht
beeinflussen ein anderer Bereich den Sie
jetzt angesprochen hatten war auch vor
in der Punkt von der AFD ist mit Blick
auf die Fragen die es auch vorhin gab
der hat mir ein Gerichtsurteil wo gesagt
wurde dass der eine zuständige einreisen
muss zugleich hatten wir ein Hinweis auf
gefälschte Dokumente bei dem gehe ich
nach im Sinne unseres recht Staates wenn
ein Gerichtsurteil sagt derjenige reist
jetzt ein dann reißt der ein weil das
ist Gericht so festgestellt hat wenn ich
ein Hinweis habe auf gefälschte
Dokumente mit dem nach gemeinsam mit dem
Innenministerium weswegen wir gesagt
haben mit Blick auf die Visa die das
betrifft wir wollen die zusätzlich
überprüfen da den Menschen die schon ein
Visa haben aber wie sie aufgestellt
worden sind heben wir diese nicht auf
das kursiert hier so aber wir heben
diese Visa nicht auf wir können ja nicht
politisch diese Titel zurücknehmen wir
überprüfen nochmal mit Blick auf die
Sicherheit aber die Menschen die einen
Visa haben die behalten diese Wiese alle
werden aber entsprechend noch mal
überprüft vielen Dank letzter
Fragesteller jetzt ist der Kollege Graf
lambsdorf
FDP-Fraktion
es ist dieser Koalition wichtig die
Widerstandskraft der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft zu stärken Resilienz ist
das Stichwort dazu
und der Präsident des
Bundesnachrichtendienstes hat in einer
öffentlichen Anhörung im Bundestag
erklärt die Abhängigkeit von Russland
das war ein Sturm die Abhängigkeit von
China das ist der Klimawandel
ihren Ausführungen entnehme ich dass sie
das genauso sehen sie haben eben sehr
stark über den Absatz in China
gesprochen China für China aber es geht
ja auch um das sourcing also das
Beschaffen von Vorprodukten von
Rohstoffen und so weiter würden Sie mir
zustimmen dass im Interesse einer
besseren Diversifizierung einer
beschleunigten Diversifizierung eine
umfassende Handelsliberalisierung mit
anderen Teilen der Welt ein gutes
Instrument wäre um diesen Klimawandel
Widerstandskraft entgegensetzen zu
können
ich stimme Ihnen bei der Analyse zu ich
stimme Ihnen auch zu dass wir
diversifizieren müssen all das umfasst
dann auch die ganzen Besuche
beziehungsweise Gespräche die wir führen
weswegen wir eben nicht nur nicht in der
Strategie haben sondern der Indopazifik
Strategie um zu diversifizieren um an
anderen Standorten der Welt auch zu
produzieren um auch stärker mit Blick
auf Freihandelsabkommen das zu
ermöglichen und zwar schnell aber sie
haben jetzt gesagt absolut auf der
ganzen Welt mit jeder Region natürlich
das was wir uns für China anschauen
begeben wir uns neue Abhängigkeiten
werden da grundlegende Fragen der
Zusammenarbeit von fair und gerecht mit
unterstützt das schauen wir uns auch mit
anderen Regionen an zum Glück gibt es
sehr sehr viele Partner im Nord im Süd
im Osten West auf dieser Welt die genau
unsere Vorstellung von einer
regelbasierten Ordnung Teilen die nicht
alles machen wie wir Europäer zum Glück
aber die das Verständnis haben dass wir
auf internationalen Recht Verträge
abschließen und das werden wir
intensivieren
vielen Dank Frau Ministerin für die
Beantwortung der Fragen damit beende ich
die Befragung ich rufe auch das waren
tatsächlich knappe zwei Stunden sogar
die hier die beiden Ministerinnen
Annalena baerbock und Bettina stark
Watzinger hier den Abgeordneten Rede und
Antwort standen und es gab ja auch sehr
viele Fragen zu Außenpolitik aber auch
zu Bildungen
Forschungspolitik in dieser
regierungsbefragung so jetzt ähm wird
hier die Fragestunde aufgerufen da
nehmen immer Staatssekretäre dann
Stellung zu verschiedenen Fragen der
Abgeordneten wir melden uns wieder wenn
die Aktuelle Stunde beginnt beantragt
heute von der Unionsfraktion zum Thema
weiter Nutzung der Kernkraft die jetzt
geht es aber erstmal weiter mit meinem
Kollegen Florian Bauer in Bonn